Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt.
Mein Name ist Tim Pridlaff und ich begrüße alle zur Ausgabe Nummer 129 von UKW.
Und ja, ich denke, ihr werdet alle meiner Meinung sein, dass mal wieder Zeit ist,
diesmal nicht erst nach drei Monaten die aktuelle Situation rund um den Ukraine-Krieg zu besprechen,
nämlich mit Pavel. Hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Und auch wenn wir gerade sieben Stunden Zeitzonen-Differenz haben,
haben wir uns hier zusammengefunden.
Bei mir ist es recht spät, aber naja, was soll's,
wir müssen ran, denn Dinge passieren und nachdem wir in der letzten Sendung
einige Thesen aufgestellt haben,
wie es denn nun mit dem Antritt der Trump-Regierung letzten Endes in diesem
Konflikt und überhaupt so weitergeht, gehen kann,
haben wir jetzt erste Datenpunkte erhalten,
wenn man es mal zurückhaltend formulieren möchte, die vielleicht schon mal in
eine gewisse Richtung weisen und ihr werdet mir sicherlich alle zustimmen,
things are happening und die Scheiße wird schon ganz ordentlich durch den Ventilator
gequirlt und wir stehen da und schauen uns das Geschehen aus der Ferne an.
Ja, es ist einfach wirklich, wirklich schwierig, den Überblick zu behalten für jeden.
Also täglich ändert sich auch die Situation und ja,
was wir haben, ist einfach ein komplettes Chaos international und auch innenpolitisch in den USA.
Ja, geht gerade ziemlich viel Porzellan zu Bruch. Das kann man,
glaube ich, schon mal festhalten.
Und ja, Trump verhält sich aus meiner Sicht wie ein Elefant im Porzellanladen.
Und die Metapher habe interessanterweise auch nicht nur ich alleine gefunden,
sondern von verschiedenen Kommentatoren auch.
Gehört. Ja.
Da würde ich sagen, let's dive right in. Ich denke, wir müssen jetzt auch erstmal
so ein bisschen zusammenfegen, was denn nun eigentlich passiert ist.
Das wird jetzt sicherlich keine vollständige Erzählung werden,
aber zumindest so die wichtigsten Eckpunkte,
wollen wir auf jeden Fall erstmal so ein bisschen ins Regal stellen,
um dann mal so ein bisschen darüber nachzudenken, was denn das nun eigentlich konkret bedeutet.
Ja, ein Kommentar haben ja auch einige uns schon darauf hingewiesen,
dass wir vielleicht nicht mit allen unseren Thesen richtig lagen.
Wer kann schon korrekt in die Zukunft schauen, aber auf der anderen Seite würde
ich auch sagen, not all is lost, das werden wir jetzt mal so Stück für Stück herausarbeiten.
Ja, also es ging los, sagen wir mit Trump außenpolitisch erstmal,
also dass er einen Handelskrieg mit Mexiko und Kanada vom Zaun gebrochen hat,
mit wirklich fragwürdigen Begründungen.
Auf der einen Seite, weil Kanada angeblich irgendwie ein Schmarotzer ist und
weil irgendwie auch Drogen und illegale Einwanderer über die Grenze strömen.
Und dann sozusagen gedroht, ja, eben mit Handelszöllen, was ein bisschen irrsinnig
ist und wie sich das am Ende entwickelt.
Also er hat die halt angekündigt und dann erstmal einen Monat ausgesetzt und ja.
25 Prozent auf nahezu alles, ich glaube 10 Prozent auf Energie.
Dazu muss man wissen, den Großteil der Energieexporte, also der kanadischen
Energieexporte geht in die USA und davon profitiert natürlich auch die USA.
Wenn sie darauf nun Zölle erheben und das ist ja generell der Wahnwitz mit seinen
merkwürdigen Theorien rund um Zölle, dann bedeutet das, dass halt die amerikanische
Wirtschaft damit belastet wird.
Erst wenn quasi die Kanadier ihr Zeug in den USA nicht mehr los werden und die
USA sich dann dasselbe von woanders holen, ist es ja eigentlich erst für das Land ein Problem,
also in dem Moment, wo du nicht mehr konkurrenzfähig bist.
Aber das ist bei den Energielieferungen, soweit ich das verstanden habe, relativ wichtig.
Das ist unwahrscheinlich. Einerseits hat Kanada nicht sehr viele andere Optionen.
Die haben nicht die Möglichkeit, Overseas zu verschiffen.
Andererseits ist das halt immer noch quasi die billigste Quelle.
Kann natürlich sein, dass die sich dann auf einmal in Saudi-Arabien eindecken, aber das ist absurd.
Aber gleichzeitig, ja, was jetzt auch wieder kürzlich gekommen ist,
ist, dass Trump irgendwie Bau einer Pipeline nach Kanada fordert,
irgendwie Pipeline-Kapazitäten in Kanada auszubauen, ja, das kommt auch noch dazu.
Und die andere Sache ist, ja, die Automobilindustrie hat sich halt arbeitsteilig
entwickelt zwischen Kanada und den USA.
Das kommt auch noch dazu.
Das heißt, die USA haben halt in Kanada sehr viel investiert in bestimmte Firmen.
Das heißt, dort besteht Expertise und bestimmte Dinge können dort einfach billiger
und in höherer Qualität gefertigt werden.
Und klar, du könntest jetzt nochmal zig Milliarden in den USA investieren.
Und dann, ja, also es macht jedenfalls alles überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Also wenn man da versucht, irgendwie
einen Sinn rein zu interpretieren in das, was da passiert, das...
Das ist fast unmöglich. Plus, das natürlich außerdem dann als Ziel angegeben
hat, Kanada als Bundesstaat zu annektieren.
Und gleichzeitig aber natürlich jetzt durch Steuern halt, durch die Zölle dann
für mehr Einnahmen zu sorgen und dadurch dann Steuern zu senken.
Wobei die Zölle natürlich auch nichts anderes als eine Flat Tax sind.
Das heißt, die sind nicht progressiv.
Das heißt, Reiche zahlen dann genauso viel Zollsteuer wie ärmere Leute.
Das heißt, es ist gleichzeitig auch noch dann, wenn du auf Zölle umschwenkst,
ist das halt auch nochmal eine Umverteilung oder ein Rückgang von Umverteilung.
Aber der Punkt ist, dass Stolleinnahmen, selbst wenn du absurd hohe Zölle erhebst.
Einfach niemals die direkten Steuern auf Einkommen ersetzen können.
Da müsstest du dann sowas wie hunderte Prozent, so 300, 400,
500 Prozent Steuern erheben.
Und das kann nicht funktionieren.
Vor allen Dingen, wenn dann die Leute tatsächlich im Innern,
also dann würden die Leute, wenn alle Importe fünfmal so teuer sind,
substituieren die Leute natürlich dann doch mit inländisch produzierten Waren
ganz, ganz schnell und dann brechen dir deine Tolle zusammen.
Das heißt, das macht alles vorne und hinten, egal wie du es kombinierst. Also...
Was auch dazu kommt, ist ja, dass mittlerweile sich dann eben auch in Kanada
natürlich viele dann auch jetzt um neue Quellen bei bestimmten Produkten,
Zulieferindustrie umsehen, weil die jetzt keinen Bock haben,
sich da hohe Kosten aufheißen zu lassen, wenn sie denn andere Optionen haben
und gehen dann eher nach Europa,
wo sie mit Sicherheit keine Strafzölle bekommen.
Zu dem Zölle und Europa, kommen wir vielleicht noch, da du Mexiko ja auch mit erwähnt hast.
Das war ja quasi so mit im Paket und beide haben sich dann auch zeitgleich auf
diese 30 Tage Verzögerung geeinigt, die im Wesentlichen eigentlich nur ein Einknicken von Trump war.
Die haben dann alle so getan, als würden sie irgendwelche Zugeständnisse machen,
aber das waren alles Dinge, die sie sowieso schon zugestanden hatten,
also mehr Truppen an der Grenze und so ein Quatsch.
Naja, und auch die mexikanische Präsidentin, Präsidentin, die Claudia Scheinbaum,
die hat da wohl auch schon die richtige Strategie am Start.
Die sind alle so ein bisschen vorbereitet, die wissen irgendwie, wie Trump tickt.
Das ist natürlich alles auch eine Gefährdung, ganz klar eine Destabilisierung,
aber der Gewinner dieser ganzen Zollpolitik kann eigentlich nur China lauten.
Ja und gerade die Kanadier natürlich, also die gerade sagen mit Kanada als 51.
US-Bundesland, Und das hat natürlich die Kanadier auch, glaube ich,
so persönlich getroffen.
Das ist eine Beleidigung.
Ist das?
Ja, und das hat dann jetzt natürlich auch gleich zu einem Boykott von US-Waren
geführt und zur Stornierung von Reisen in die USA.
Also die USA ist auch das Hauptreiseland der Kanadier und eben da lassen da
irgendwie 20 Milliarden jedes Jahr und das ist natürlich auch nicht schön.
Ja, aber das ist ja nicht das Einzige, was er wollte. Er wollte ja dann auch
noch Grönland annektieren.
Auch so eine geile Idee.
Ja, oder kaufen.
Kaufen, annektieren, was auch immer. Er ist ja auch nicht klar in seinen Aussagen.
Er labert so daher und lässt auch alles irgendwie offen. Es gibt ja auch nicht wirklich einen Plan.
Klar, diese Begehrlichkeiten ist
halt so Ausdruck so einer typischen Großmannssucht auf der einen Seite.
Auf der anderen Seite kann man auch sagen, egal was er da formuliert,
es hat irgendwie immer was mit fossilen Ressourcen zu tun oder mit Zugang zum Real Estate.
Ja, oder Re-Claritorium.
Genau, es hat alles irgendwie was mit Real Estate zu tun und mit irgendwelchen
Vergeltungsmaßnahmen gegen irgendwelche unliebsamen Menschen und Voke-Regierungen
und was nicht alles. Das ist alles ein bisschen albern.
Ich meine, diese Grönland-Nummer war dann natürlich dann auch ein Affront gegen Dänemark, ganz klar.
Also natürlich vor allem auch gegen Grönland, aber natürlich auch gegen Dänemark
so als Schutzmacht Grönlands.
Und ich meine, das ist halt alles irgendwie total absurd.
Andererseits ist halt alles total absurd, was er macht.
Und ja, manche Dinge werden geschehen,
auch wenn ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt sowohl bei diesen Zöllen als auch bei der
Übernahme von Grönland oder Kanada als Bundesstaat, das fällt für mich alles
eher in die Kategorie, da werden wir jetzt viel drüber geredet und gelacht und
geschimpft haben, aber passieren wird da nichts.
Also Wall Street hatte wohl 5% overall Zollerhöhungen eingeplant durch Trump.
Und das hat sich aber jetzt gewandelt.
Man befürchtet, dass im Endeffekt es mehr werden wird an Zellen jetzt.
Aber wir hatten ja noch weitere Übernahmeankündigungen.
Panama-Kanal war da auch mittendrin irgendwo.
Dann kam der absolute Hit, nämlich den Gazastreifen zu übernehmen.
Das war irgendwie die Kirsche wirklich auf der Torte.
Und ich meine, das Problem natürlich ist,
dass das Ganze jetzt auch massiv den Friedensprozess zu torpedieren droht,
der dort gerade abläuft, so zwischen Israel und den Palästinensern,
weil letztlich, ich meine gut, Trump hat gesagt, ja,
wir übernehmen den Besen rein quasi, beziehungsweise ohne Leute.
Die Leute werden irgendwohin umgesiedelt, wo es viel schöner ist.
Und dann geht die USA rein und räumt alles schön auf und baut halt irgendwie schicke Wohnungen.
Die neue Riviera soll das werden, soll das auch wieder, ja, Immobilienentwickler Trump.
Am Werk.
In dem Zusammenhang, ich meine, das ist natürlich alles total hanebüchener Unsinn.
Niemals werden die Amerikaner in den Gazastreifen einfallen und irgendwie mit
militärischer Macht versuchen dort vorzugehen, weil das wäre ein totales Chaos,
bei dem die amerikanischen Soldaten so viel Schaden nehmen würden.
Das wäre niemals zu Hause zu verkaufen und ist ohnehin total absurd und ausgeschlossen.
Trotzdem, das werden wir jetzt glaube ich schon noch ein paar Mal sehen,
hat es dann wiederum deswegen Bewegungen gegeben im arabischen Blog,
die dann gesagt haben, wir machen das hier mit dem Development,
wir machen jetzt hier drei Jahre Wiederaufbau und so jetzt kommt dann halt irgendwie
so Saudi-Arabien, keine Ahnung, wer da noch alles mit im Boot ist in dieser
Allianz und wollen das sozusagen übernehmen, weil das natürlich für sie überhaupt
nicht zu verkaufen wäre.
Ja, also das ist sozusagen, also.
Man darf nicht davon ausgehen, weil dafür gibt es keinerlei Evidenz,
dass irgendeine dieser arabischen Staaten rund um Israel herum,
nehmen wir vielleicht erstmal Jordanien mal raus, Aber auf jeden Fall nicht
Ägypten, schon gar nicht Saudi-Arabien.
Für die ist Palästina ein politisches, heikles Thema,
weil natürlich die Bevölkerung den Widerstand oder die Freiheit der Palästinenser
mehrheitlich unterstützt.
Das ist natürlich auch vollkommen klar, aber real, die Regierungen tun halt
für Palästinenser gar nichts. Da werden nie Flüchtlinge aufgenommen.
Die wollen keine Palästinenser haben, weil sich das halt extrem destabilisierend
ausgewirkt hat in der Vergangenheit, als die Flüchtlingswellen da waren.
Das hätte fast zum Sturz der Regierung geführt. Und es hat in den Nachbarländern
überall nur Probleme geschaffen,
weshalb ja auch die Grenze zu Ägypten irgendwie fast undurchlässiger ist,
als die zu Israel oder war.
Ja, also ist so. Nach Israel sind sie alle rein und haben dort gearbeitet.
Das hat mit Ägypten nicht stattgefunden.
Ja.
Ja, also das ist auch natürlich wieder nur so eine Erzählung und man weiß halt
immer nicht so ganz genau,
ob er einfach nicht in der Lage ist, das Maul zu halten, was ich für relativ wahrscheinlich halte.
Er plappert halt einfach irgendwas so daher.
Oder ob es sozusagen eine Strategie ist von ihm. Das weiß ich nicht.
Es macht schon den Eindruck, dass es einen strategischen Anteil hat,
indem er einfach durch diese ganzen Erzählungen permanent Verwirrung,
Chaos, Ablenkung und Unsicherheit schafft, was ihm irgendwie gefällt,
weil dann reden halt alle über ihn.
Das ist eigentlich im Wesentlichen alles, was das bewirkt und wahrscheinlich
auch der einzige Grund, warum es diese Erzählung überhaupt gibt.
Ja, dann habe ich heute erfahren, dass Trump Taiwan mit 100 Prozent Zoll auf Chips gedroht hat.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du das schon mitbekommen hast.
Nein, ich bin zwar in Taiwan gerade, aber das habe ich heute noch nicht mitbekommen.
Interessant. Also ich meine mehr kann man sich ja kaum ins Fleisch schneiden
als mit so einer Maßnahme und was ist die Argumentation?
Was hat jetzt Taiwan Böses getan als einer der stärksten Verbündeten der USA?
Naja, die sollen die Chips gefälligsten in den USA produzieren.
Achso, ja klar. Logisch, logisch. Das geht ja auch so leicht.
Genau.
Das werden sie ja sicherlich einfach so abgeben. 100 Prozent,
da wird sich ja die Computerindustrie und die Tech-Pros werden sich ja richtig freuen.
Also wäre auch relativ,
absurd. Aber ja, das ist unter anderem eine auch seiner Äußerungen gewesen.
In dem Zusammenhang muss man dann auch nochmal betonen, das wissen ja vielleicht auch viele nicht.
Einerseits, wie wichtig ist Taiwan?
Taiwan ist ja nicht nur irgendein Chip-Hersteller. Taiwan ist der Chip-Hersteller dieser Welt.
Die besten, modernsten, und zwar mit Abstand, modernsten Chips mit Abstand dem
größten Ausstoß kommen aus Taiwan.
TSMC ist hier quasi so eine Überfirma, so wie Samsung in Korea.
Nicht, weil sie die alles mögliche herstellen von Waschmaschinen und so weiter.
Das ist kein Siemens-Konzern, aber sie sind halt in der Chip-Manufaktur so wichtig
und so groß und so heilig hier in Taiwan und so groß.
Für den wirtschaftlichen Aufschwung dieses Landes so verantwortlich,
das kann man gar nicht ausreichend betonen, welche Bedeutung das hat.
Und die gesamte Elektronikbranche der Welt und vor allem natürlich die der USA hängt von Taiwan ab.
Also du hast halt irgendwie, ohne TSMC gibt es keine iPhones und es ist halt
vollkommen absurd, dass sie sich sozusagen selber dann die Preise verdoppeln,
weil damit sich halt einen riesigen Vorteil, dass sie nämlich diesen Zugriff auf Taiwan haben,
wo einem Land, was den USA super gewogen ist durch die ganze Vergangenheit,
dadurch, dass halt die USA hier immer Schutz macht, war,
du bist hier in einem Land, was zwar auf der einen Seite irgendwie sich wie
China anfühlt, Aber auf der anderen Seite sehr amerikanisch daherkommt.
Hier gibt es irgendwie amerikanische Steckdosen mit 120 Woll.
Das ist so ein bisschen, ich will nicht sagen eine Außenstelle der USA,
aber du spürst zumindest, wie die Verbindung ist und die Verbindung ist halt stark.
Und das halt jetzt mit solchen Anwesendkündigungen zu strafen,
ist natürlich vollkommen absurd.
Ja, also DSNC verbraucht, glaube ich, 12 Prozent der elektrischen Energie,
die in Taiwan verbraucht wird, sozusagen alleine, nur um mal klarzumachen und.
Ja, es sorgt für, ich glaube, diese Chips machen irgendwie über die Hälfte des
taiwanesischen Außenhandels aus.
Und dann ist es aber noch eben wichtig als eben Silicon Shield,
also sicherheitspolitisch, weil sie eben diese Rolle haben als Chip-Produzent der Welt.
Die Welt und insbesondere die Amerikaner auf sie aufpassen und dafür sorgen,
dass das nicht durch in chinesische Hände gerät oder durch China irgendwie gestört wird.
Aber wenn Trump natürlich jetzt sagt, okay, ich will jetzt die Chip-Produktion
nach Hause holen und Taiwan, ja,
und unabhängig von Taiwan oder unabhängiger von Taiwan werden,
ist das natürlich bad news für den Silicon Shield.
So, wobei auch wieder da völlig unklar ist, in welchem Maße denn das gelingen
wird, weil das ist gerade, also Chipproduktion ist so Kapital und Know-how aufwendig.
Ja das geht einfach gar nicht so, also selbst wenn die das wollen würden,
was sie natürlich aus guten Gründen nicht wollen, weil es natürlich ihr Vorteil
ist, warum sollten sie die Spitzenentwicklung auf einmal in den USA machen,
sie bauen ja da auch Fabriken, ist ja nicht so, dass nicht gemacht wird,
aber eben nicht diese Top Level Chips, diese drei Nanometer und kleineren,
die machen sie halt nicht woanders.
Ich glaube, die USA hat jetzt irgendwie eine 4-Nanometer-Fabrik oder so.
Aber auch, ich meine, das andere Problem ist, dass halt die Chip-Fertigung auch
eigentlich ein undankbares Geschäft ist, was halt vielen Zyklen unterworfen ist.
Früher gab es halt diesen Rammschweine-Zyklus.
Und sie ist halt eben auch sehr kompetitiv. man jetzt am Niedergang von Intel sehen kann,
wo Intel, die ja quasi technologisch jetzt ein bisschen ins Hintertreffen geraten
ist und gerade massiv am Abstürzen.
Das heißt, selbst wenn du jetzt die Industrie nach Hause holst, ist damit nicht gesagt,
dass die da überlebensfähig ist, weil natürlich die Entwicklung weitergeht und
du die ganze Zeit am Ball bleiben musst. Und das ist halt kapitalintensiv.
Und in dem Moment, wo du dann nur kurzzeitig ins Hintertreffen gerätst für zwei,
drei Jahre, so lohnt sich das alles nicht mehr.
Du hast so keine State-of-the-Art-Produktion mehr.
In Deutschland kriegen wir jetzt auch ein paar neue TSMC-Fabriken.
Ansiedlungen in Dresden. Ich meine, die machen schon auch woanders was.
Aber der Kern wird immer sein.
Aber wenn jetzt tatsächlich 100 Prozent, ist vollkommen absurd.
Sagen wir mal, sie würden das jetzt machen. Er macht so, ja,
ab nächster Woche kosten die Chips irgendwie das Doppelte.
Das hauen ihm seine Tech-Pros links und rechts. und die gesamte Elektronikindustrie
der USA haut ihm das um die Ohren, weil sie sozusagen von heute auf morgen auf
dem Weltmarkt nicht mehr mithalten können.
Also ich meine, Nvidia kriegt seine ganzen Chips daher, das würde also sofort Nvidia wäre tot.
In China knallen die Sektkorten. Andererseits müssten sie sie trotzdem kaufen,
weil sie sie ja nirgendwo anders herbekommen und Taiwan wäre es halt eigentlich dann auch egal.
Auch wenn ihr natürlich auf diesen Stress überhaupt gar keinen Bock haben.
Ja, dann gab es auch natürlich eine Androhung an die EU, sagen dort,
Zölle auf Waren aus der EU zu erheben.
Aber konkretisiert wurde das bisher noch nicht.
Ich meine, das Problem mit diesen ganzen Zöllen ist, das ist halt eben absolut
Und auch unstrategisch und komplett exzessiv und einfach, ja,
ich sage deswegen, der Handelskrieg mit Kanada wurde als der dümmste Handelskrieg
der Geschichte bezeichnet schon, weil, ja, das kann aber...
Da kommen wir später noch dazu, was das innenpolitisch dann für die USA denn bedeuten würde.
Dann ist mir gerade heute eine Drohung, die auch an Europa gerichtet ist,
aber eigentlich sich auf die gesamte Welt bezieht, aber speziell sehr nach Europa klingt.
Nämlich eine Anweisung, eine Drohung an alle Länder,
die Steuern erheben oder irgendwie Auflagen machen, die US-Firmen überproportional benachteiligen.
Sowas wie eine Digital Service Tax oder so.
Also wenn jetzt die USA der Meinung ist, dass Facebook oder Twitter ungerecht
besteuert werden in der EU, gedenken sie dagegen vorzugehen.
Oder gegen Datenschutzbestimmungen, die den Datenfluss in die USA behindern.
Oder Geldstrafen, die gegen US-Konzerne verhängt werden.
Das muss sein.
Dann, was ja schon mehrmals passiert ist,
kam die Drohung, hat die USA gedroht seinen NATO-Verpflichtungen nicht nachzukommen,
also Artikel 5, nach dem Motto, wer nicht zahlt, wird auch nicht geschützt.
Ja, das gab es ja schon in seiner ersten Amtszeit, solche Drohungen.
Generell, ich meine, das ist sicherlich wertvoll, hier nochmal ein bisschen
darauf einzugehen, dass diese Sicherheit,
dass die USA ein stabiler Bündnispartner sind, dass das weg ist.
Ich glaube, das war ja von Anfang an schon klar, weil das hat sich ja in der
letzten Amtszeit schon abgezeichnet und daran hat sich jetzt eigentlich wenig geändert.
Ich glaube, da ist die NATO in gewisser Hinsicht auch schon darauf vorbereitet.
Aber es kann halt durchaus sein, dass er in irgendeiner Form den Todesstoß versetzt.
Und wenn wir noch viel darüber reden, dann muss Europa natürlich reagieren.
Und dann, was natürlich ein kompletter Affront war, war, dass er Verhandlungen
mit Russland begonnen hat unter Ausschluss der Ukraine und Europa.
So nach dem Motto, wir machen das jetzt unter uns aus und hat dann mit Zelensky begonnen,
hat Zelensky einen Diktator genannt,
hat irgendwie andere russische Positionen übernommen.
Insbesondere die Ukraine hätte den Krieg nie beginnen sollen.
Viele interpretieren das als wenn Trump gesagt hätte,
dass die Ukraine den Krieg begonnen hätte im Sinne von sie hätte Russland überfallen.
Aber was Trump eigentlich gemeint hat mit, die Ukraine hätte sich nicht wehren
sollen, als die Russen einmarschiert sind.
Das ist grandios.
Das meinte er mit dem Krieg nicht beginnen. Sie hätten einfach die russischen
Truppen gewähren lassen sollen,
hätten einfach keinen Widerstand leisten und dann wäre auch alles gut gewesen.
Oder besser.
Grandios.
Ja, und dann...
Sind so einige Dinge dann bekannt geworden von dem Treffen über den sogenannten Peace-Deal,
die so im Westen und in der Ukraine massiv Bestürzung hervorgerufen haben und
in Russland für absoluten Jubel und Verwirrung gesorgt haben.
Also das war so ein Bündel von Dingen.
Also erst mal hat Trump eine NATO-Mitgliedschaft in der Ukraine ausgeschlossen,
von vornherein, ohne das irgendwie als Verhandlungsmasse vielleicht zu nehmen.
Hat außerdem dann eben Neuwahlen in der Ukraine gefordert,
was auch so ein Kreml-Ding ist,
die gerne einfach Selenskyj weg hätten und dann einen russlandfreundlichen Präsidenten,
und da sozusagen die Hoffnung besteht.
Jetzt dann durch Neuwahlen und durch Manipulation,
Wahlmanipulation dann eben jemanden an die Macht zu kriegen,
der ja nicht Zelensky ist und eher im Sinne von Moskau handelt.
Und hat außerdem, hat Trump ausgeschlossen, dass die Ukraine sein Territorium zurückerhält.
So, dem Motto, ja, besetzt, nach dem Motto, besetzt ist besetzt.
Und beziehungsweise er hat halt nicht genau gesagt, also nichts Konkretes natürlich,
aber nur, dass es ausgeschlossen sei, dass Ukraine sein ganzes Territorium zurückerhält.
Was im Übrigen ein Verstoß ist gegen damals das Budapester Memorandum,
wo die USA dafür, dass die Ukraine die Atomwaffen abgegeben hat,
nicht nur die USA, sondern Großbritannien und Russland, die territoriale Integrität
der Ukraine dafür garantiert haben.
Und dann hat aus dem Ausgeschlossen, dass US-Truppen für Friedenssicherung eingesetzt werden.
Und hat also gesagt, okay,
Europa muss also im Prinzip, wenn Friedenstruppen und dann,
wenn aber dadurch dann Verbündete die Friedenstruppen schicken,
deswegen angegriffen werden wegen ihrem Ukraine-Engagement,
wäre das kein Artikel-5-Pall.
Für die NATO.
Für die NATO, genau.
Also kein Bündnisfile, wo die USA in irgendeiner Form Unterstützung bieten muss.
Genau.
Man muss in dem Zusammenhang immer wieder erwähnen, dieser Artikel 5 ist bisher
genau ein einziges Mal zum Einsatz gekommen bisher und das war als die USA angegriffen wurde,
9-11 und wo dann irgendwie alle Bündnispartner eingesprungen sind und die USA
bei ihrer militärischen Antwort geholfen hat.
Ja, und hat aber behauptet, Putin würde europäische Friedenstruppen in der Ukraine
akzeptieren, was ich mit drei großen Fragezeichen versehen würde,
weil ja,
plus das öffnet auch nochmal einen riesigen Rattenschwanz.
Aber das Thema kann man auch nochmal später ein bisschen genauer beleuchten, was das denn bedeutet.
Und dann hat er außerdem aber noch einen Rohstoffdeal mit der Ukraine gefordert, hat sie dann gesagt.
Vor dem Meeting mit Putin nochmal den Finanzminister hingeschickt mit einem
Vertrag, den Selenskyj dann unterschreiben sollte,
der ihnen dann 50 Prozent von allen ukrainischen Rohstoffeinnahmen garantiert,
bis die Summe von 500 Milliarden zusammengekommen ist.
Wenn es Selenskyj dann nicht getan hat. Ja genau.
Ja, plus andere Dinge, was Selenskyj dann nicht getan hat.
Daraufhin gab es dann eben diese Diktatoräußerungen und andere Dinge.
Und der aktuelle Stand ist,
dass Selenskyj jetzt Ende der Woche angeblich in die USA kommen soll,
um dort einen jetzt nachverhandelten Rohstoffdeal zu unterzeichnen.
Und wenn der Witz an der ganzen Sache ist, dass völlig unklar ist,
ob diese Rohstoffe überhaupt existieren oder ob es sich überhaupt lohnt oder
welchen Wert die eigentlich haben, weil es gibt keine aktuellen Surveys.
Es gibt irgendwie nur 50 Jahre alte sowjetische Surveys.
Aber gut, auf jeden Fall, das ist der aktuelle Stand, ob Zelensky wirklich kommt,
ob sie wirklich unterzeichnen werden.
Aber kann schon gut sein.
Dass das ja jetzt passiert und damit dann im Prinzip die Idee ist,
dass dann die USA einen Grund haben, die Ukraine zu schützen,
weil ohne Schutz der Ukraine gibt es halt auch keine Kohle aus den Rohstoffen.
Ja, naja, ich denke zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt kann die Ukraine eh schon nicht
mehr davon ausgehen, dass irgendein Vertrag, wo draufsteht, ja wir beschützen
euch schon, am Ende auch wirklich,
dass das Geld wert ist, was das Papier kostet, auf dem es steht.
Und ich denke, die Ukraine wäre sehr gut damit beraten, überhaupt gar keinen
konkreten Vertrag zu unterschreiben zu diesem Zeitpunkt, zumindest keinen Vertrag,
der weitreichende Folgen hat.
Sondern der, sagen wir mal, Dinge offen lässt und ankündigt und irgendwie,
also im besten Fall irgendetwas mit dem Trump so tun kann, als hätte er irgendwie
einen geilen Deal gehabt, weil darum
geht es ihm ja immer, wo aber am Ende eigentlich gar nichts klar ist.
Und ich denke auch, dass die Ukraine in zunehmendem Maße auch an einem immer
längeren Hebel sitzt, was solche Vertragsverhandlungen betrifft.
Ja, na klar, USA ist derzeit noch sehr wichtig mit Informationen,
mit Starlink und so weiter.
Es gab jetzt auch erste Gerüchte, dass auch schon damit gedroht wurde,
Starlink abzuschalten für die Ukrainer.
Also sie setzen halt irgendwie alles ein und auch diese sogenannten Verhandlungen,
die da in Saudi-Arabien stattfinden zwischen Russland und den USA,
die sind ja insofern auch sehr interessant, als dass, also klar von Russland
nehmen halt so die üblichen Verdächtigen, Lavrov und so weiter teil,
alles sozusagen super erfahrene Leute,
die Truppe, die Trump dahin geschickt hat, ist total unerfahren.
Aber halt so Loyalisten und Rechtsextreme und so weiter und diese Truppe dort
verhandelt halt in dem Sinne gar nicht auch über einen Frieden.
Es wird ja immer die ganze Zeit gesagt, die würden da irgendwelche Friedensverhandlungen
führen. stellt sich raus, es geht halt auch hier eigentlich um einen Deal mit Rohstoffen.
Also jetzt bietet quasi Russland den USA an, ja hier Rohstoffe und so weiter
haben wir auch ganz viele.
Wenn ihr daran interessiert seid, da braucht ihr jetzt die Ukraine gar nicht.
Abgesehen davon könnt ihr ja dann auch die irgendwie in den besetzten Gebieten
dann abbauen, weil das ist ja jetzt alles Russland.
Ja, also Russland Verkaufen sozusagen in den USA, dann irgendwie die ukrainischen
Mineralien und was da alles liegt.
Also völlig gaga, völlig super absurd.
Und ich denke an der Stelle, wir werden das Thema sicherlich noch ein paar Mal
haben, muss man halt auch mal ganz klar machen, was ja eigentlich gerade stattfindet.
Dass nämlich.
Keine internationalen Verhandlungen sind. Ich meine, die Ukraine ist nicht beteiligt.
Die EU ist nicht beteiligt. Die USA redet quasi mit Russland über ein Land,
was irgendwie im Krieg ist und das Land ist selber nicht dabei. Völlig absurd.
Und die führen da auch gar keine Friedensverhandlungen, weil das geht so gar
nicht. Das würde viel länger dauern.
Du brauchst da kompetente Leute für, die sie nicht haben.
Selbst dieser Beauftragte für die Ukraine, der anfangs als Beauftragter für
die Ukraine und Russland genannt wurde, dieser Kellogg, verhandelt nicht mit
den Russen, sondern stattdessen macht das irgendwie einer, der für Nahost zuständig ist.
Was auch immer das wiederum zu tun hat.
Also am Ende ist das Ganze einfach nur so ein Mafia-Dick-Move,
wo einfach sich die Super-Cronies da treffen und versuchen irgendwelche shady
Deals zu machen und das Ganze wird halt irgendwie als Politik verkauft,
aber da findet halt keine Politik statt, weil dafür sind dann einfach nicht die richtigen Leute,
da und die richtigen Leute sind halt nicht da.
Ja, zu den Folgen kommen wir auch später noch, würde ich sagen.
Genau. Gucken wir nochmal, was so innenpolitisch sich noch so aufgetan hat,
weil das ist ja auch sehr interessant.
Ja, also innenpolitisch in den USA hat die neue Regierung die Hand an den öffentlichen
Dienst gelegt, unter anderem.
Und Elon Musk mit Doge hat halt im Prinzip angefangen,
Einschüchterungs- und Entlassungswellen im öffentlichen Dienst loszutreten,
die teilweise rechtswidrig sind.
Und wo halt einfach mal mit, ja,
sie im Prinzip ein paar Skriptkiddies losgeschickt haben,
die dann Ketten-E-Mails verschickt
haben und dann pauschal nach bestimmten Stichworten Dinge gefiltert haben.
Und so in ihrem...
In ihrem Anti-DEI-Feldzug sind absurde Dinge passiert.
Sie haben ihre Nuclear Stockpile-Inspektoren-Nachwuchs versehentlich komplett
gekündigt und ihre E-Mail abgeschaltet und versucht, die Leute wieder zurückzukriegen.
Sie haben bei der FDA die Leute,
die so Herzschrittmacher und medizinisches Equipment wie CT- und MR-Scanner
zertifizieren und überwachen,
haben sich versehentlich entlassen und, und, und.
Und ja, mittlerweile gibt es natürlich jede Menge Gerichtsverfahren deswegen,
weil halt Leute klagen, weil vieles eben von dem, was da in Trumps Erlassen
steht, einfach rechtswidrig ist.
Und das macht jetzt seinen Weg rauf zum Supreme Court, der jetzt auch gerade
erstmals gegen auch Trump entschieden hat in irgendeiner Sache.
Tatsächlich? Was denn? Welcher Sache?
Das war, ich glaube, das hatte mit Entlassungen jetzt mit den Entlassungen oder Schließungen zu tun.
Und ja,
Und gut, der Punkt ist, also und zwar, ich glaube, in einem Fall,
wo es um einen Ombudsmann gegen eine Behörde, eine unabhängige Stelle und wo
der Ombudsmann gekündigt wurde, obwohl explizit im Gesetz steht,
dass das nicht geht, dass der halt nicht kündbar ist.
Und selbst die, die gekündigt wurden, nicht von der Regierung gekündigt werden dürfen. Teilweise.
Genau, oder nur aus wichtigem Grund.
Und dann impeached werden können.
Ja, also diese Einschüchterungs- und Entlassungswellen im öffentlichen Dienst
gefährden natürlich die Funktionsfähigkeit einfach des Staates auch massiv,
was auch ein bisschen irre ist,
weil es auch wiederum der Staat ist, auf den Trump eigentlich da sich stützen muss.
Wenn du natürlich irgendwas umsetzen willst, brauchst du natürlich Leute,
auch die das umsetzen und pauschal jetzt Leute zu entlassen.
Und ja, mit unglaublich beleidigenden E-Mails und auch die Leute im öffentlichen
Dienst sind jetzt in weiten Teilen auch ziemlich pisst und demoralisiert.
Also viele sagen sich, ich habe mir jetzt 10, 20, 30, 40 Jahre den Hintern aufgerissen,
so für das Land im öffentlichen Dienst oder mache hier jetzt einen wichtigen Job.
Und werde jetzt behandelt von meinem Arbeitgeber,
als wäre ich ein Schmarotzer und Nichtstuer und überflüssig und würde irgendwie
einfach nur dem Steuerzahler auf der Tasche liegen.
So, das ist mehr Zeit, dass wie die Regierung und auch die Pressesprecher gerade nach außen auftreten.
Und da sagen sich halt auch viele Leute, ey, bei so einem Arbeitgeber möchte
ich einfach nicht arbeiten.
Ja, die Bezahlung ist jetzt auch nicht so super und mit jetzt was,
achso und plus, der öffentliche Dienst ist halt zu weiten Teilen auch von Ex-Soldaten,
also da arbeiten eben viele,
auch die, die vorher in der Army eine Karriere hatten.
Werden halt eben, wurden teilweise auch bevorzugt eingestellt, eben Veteranen.
Und ja, das ist natürlich gerade ein ziemliches Desaster auch für die USA,
was auch anfängt für gewisse Unzufriedenheit zu sorgen.
Ja, dann wurden natürlich jede Menge Führungspositionen mit unqualifizierten Loyalisten besetzt,
also FBI-Direktor und auch sehr beunruhigend ja beim Militär wurde der Stabschef entlassen.
Das ist auch unüblich, das ist eigentlich eine unpolitische Position,
also der Chef des Generalstabs sind wie Joint Chief of Staffs.
Das hat kein Präsident bisher gemacht,
dass er da gewechselt hat und dann wurden eben auch die obersten Militärjuristen,
die Jacks, die obersten, wurden auch alle entlassen.
Das sind diejenigen, die dafür zu sorgen haben,
dass sich die Truppen rechtlich einwandfrei verhalten,
die ja so Rules of Engagement und Völkerrecht und all das interpretieren und
dafür sorgen, dass eben, ja,
Kriege verhindern sollen, dass die USA Kriegsverbrechen begehen.
Oder gegen die eigene Bevölkerung vorgehen oder generell rechtswidrige Dinge tun.
Und das ist natürlich auch hochgradig, unruhigend.
Generell geht er ja auch extrem gegen die Juristen vor.
Also man merkt schon, dass es hier auch um eine Schwächung des legalen Systems geht.
Also alle, die ihn irgendwie auch mal verurteilt haben oder in irgendeiner Form
daran beteiligt waren, diese 6.
Januar Umsturz irgendwie Leute zu verurteilen, sollen jetzt dafür bestraft werden,
dass sie da das Gesetz verfolgt haben.
Und das ist natürlich schon eine sehr offensichtliche Strategie und wird sich
zeigen, inwiefern das dann greift.
Also es ist halt so eine Shock and Awe Methode und vor allem darf man nie weglassen.
Es ist nicht nur Trump, sondern es ist vielleicht sogar vor allem Elon Musk,
der irgendwie ohne eine offizielle Rolle zu haben, völlig freidreht.
Auf Twitter auch die ganze Zeit, den ganzen Tag über sozusagen auf Richter einschleudert
und so die Massen aufstachelt.
Es ist also wirklich Hetze so in bester Nazi-Manier.
Also bestimmte Gruppen immer wieder als faul und als störend und antidemokratisch
und unamerikanisch darzustellen,
die einfach nur ganz normal dem Gesetz folgen und einfach auch die Stütze der
Gesellschaft sind und dieses Staates.
Und das soll halt alles aufgeweicht werden, damit eben sich niemand mehr ihm in den Weg stellen kann.
Und mit ihm meine ich sowohl Trump als auch Musk, die ja beide sozusagen zu
befürchten hatten und vielleicht noch haben, irgendwann mal für ihre ganzen
Verbrechen auch mal in den Knast geschmissen zu werden und das wollen sie halt
dahingehend verhindern.
Ein anderer Aspekt war auch noch, dass die Tatsache, dass Trump versucht,
so viele verbotene Dinge zu tun,
darauf hindeutet, dass er auch nicht vorhat.
Bei der nächsten Wahl das Amt zu geben.
Abzugeben und es gibt auch schon Kampagnen jetzt um Donald Trump eine dritte
Amtszeit zu ermöglichen.
Also die haben jetzt schon begonnen.
Also das wird auf jeden Fall auch nochmal krass werden.
Dann hat er versucht seine Massendeportation in Gang zu setzen.
Was natürlich praktisch auch erstmal nur so bedingt gut funktioniert Aber das
Üble ist, dass er jetzt quasi Quota für Deportationen ausgegeben hat.
Ihr müsst jetzt irgendwie pro Tag so und so viele illegale Ausländer verhaften,
was dann natürlich dazu geführt hat, dass die irgendwie sich jeden gegriffen
haben, der zur falschen Zeit am falschen Ort war und nicht eindeutig weiß aussah.
Ja, also Racial Profiling getriebene Verhaftungen,
was natürlich dann auch dazu führt, dass teilweise Puerto Ricaner,
die im Prinzip amerikanische Staatsbürger sind und jedenfalls das Aufenthaltsrecht haben,
da in die Fänge geraten sind oder ganz krass halt Ureinwohner,
also Indianer quasi von Eis verhaftet. Tschüss.
Das war eine Scheiße.
Und stellt sich dann raus, dass aber auch ein Großteil der Deportierten keinerlei Vorstrafen hatte.
Also weil so viele Kriminelle haben sie dann leider gar nicht finden können,
um die Quota einzuhalten.
Und dann haben sie teilweise Verhaftungen in Schulen und auf Ämtern und in Krankenhäusern
und an Arbeitsstätten durchgeführt.
Was natürlich auch ziemlich übel ist und natürlich dazu führt,
dass ja viele Migranten sich halt versteckt haben und dann nicht zum Arzt gehen
oder der Arbeit fernbleiben.
Und ganz klar dürfte natürlich, wenn du jetzt den Leuten die Möglichkeit nimmst,
sich ihr Geld legal zu verdienen oder Hilfe zu suchen,
dass das natürlich dann zu mehr Kriminalität führen wird.
Und so, was da gerade passiert.
Ja, also das war jetzt auch nur ein kleiner Abriss dessen, was sich da alles tut.
Also es waren Ende, ich sage mal, Hunderte von Verordnungen.
Großteil davon, wie erwartet, aus Project 2025.
Und ja, sie versuchen es durchzuziehen. Sehr viel sieht eben,
also sie versuchen auf jeden Fall ihre Macht auszubauen.
Und natürlich noch die Auflösung von USAID ist noch so ein Ding,
das auf jeden Fall erwähnenswert ist.
Also vermutlich größte Hilfsorganisation der Welt von Kennedy damals gegründet,
was in ganz vielen Ländern jetzt dazu geführt hat, dass medizinische Versorgung
und die Versorgung mit Nahrungsmitteln und Trinkwasser,
praktisch zum Erliegen gekommen ist und wo man dann davon ausgehen kann,
dass damit jede Menge Soft-Power einfach in den Gully gekippt wurde der USA
und dass wahrscheinlich jetzt andere Länder dort in die Fußstapfen treten werden.
Dass es gerade China natürlich das super finden wird, dass sich da Möglichkeiten
eröffnet, Wohltaten zu leisten.
Und ich fände es halt gut, wenn die EU auch die Gelegenheit nutzen würde.
Sagen jetzt EU-Aid zu starten sozusagen.
EU-Aid zu starten. Ich habe geguckt, es gibt kein Äquivalent in der EU tatsächlich.
Es gibt verschiedene Abteilungen, die unterschiedlichen Stellen angesiedelt
sind, beim Ministerrat und so eine Stelle.
Aber es gibt eben jetzt kein EU-Aid in dem Sinne.
Und ja, das wäre wahrscheinlich einmal im Sinne der Betroffenen,
die jetzt Hilfe verloren haben, wäre das eine gute Sache.
Aber auch um EU-Soft-Power auf günstige Art und Weise auszubauen.
Also in die Lücke sollten wir dringend reinstoßen, wenn die USA diesen Teil
des Einflusses ausgibt, dann eben mehr europäische Werte dann dort propagieren,
statt amerikanische Werte in den Ländern.
Ja und vor allem bei USAID steht vor allem halt Elon Musk wieder dahinter,
der das halt alles vorangetrieben hat.
Da gibt es dann halt auch noch interessante Nebenstories, weil ich meine die
USAID war unter anderem auch sehr maßgeblich daran beteiligt,
das südafrikanische Apartheid-Regime mit zu stürzen durch ihre Aktivitäten.
Es wird so ein bisschen gemunkelt, dass das hier vielleicht Teil der Motivation
sein könnte für Elon Musk, gerade hier drauf einzuschlagen.
Man fragt sich ja ohnehin. Also ich meine, warum das? Also ich meine, Effizienz.
Klar, ich meine, niemand ist dort bereit, gerade eine Gesamtrechnung aufzumachen.
Also man merkt richtig, es interessiert die alle einen Scheiß,
wie dieses Staatssystem funktioniert.
Es geht nur darum, alles raushauen, was uns irgendwie in den Knast bringen kann.
Alles raushauen, was in irgendeiner Form.
Für Gleichheit sorgt. Also dieser Wahn der Republikaner und der Rechtsradikalen,
irgendwie so diesem Vokism, irgendwas entgegenzusetzen.
Also alles, was irgendwie gut tut, muss irgendwie weg.
Ja, also kein Schutz mehr für Transmenschen, für Schwule, für Minderheiten und
so weiter. Das ist alles irgendwie böses Zeug.
Also im Prinzip so eine zutiefst rassistische Agenda, die hier angesetzt wird.
Und Hauptsache der Staat wird nicht in die Lage versetzt, böse Aktoren zu verfolgen,
zu verurteilen und böse handelnde Unternehmen zu kontrollieren.
Weil natürlich in der Umweltbehörde an vielen Stellen, in der Steuerbehörde,
überall diese Stellen gestrichen werden, die halt irgendwie erforderlich einfach
sind, um Steuern einzutreiben, um Steuerhinterzieher zu finden etc.
Und so geht es halt am laufenden Meter und das Ganze im Im Wochentakt.
Dazu eben auch noch diese unsägliche Art und Weise von Elon Musk,
der dann irgendwie allen Bediensten irgendwelche E-Mails schicken lässt mit,
ja, wenn ihr nicht innerhalb einer Woche nachweist, was ihr irgendwie Tolles
und Wichtiges getan habt, dann
werdet ihr entlassen, wenn ihr nicht antwortet, es fliegt sofort raus.
Illegal, aber trotzdem haben halt die Republikaner bisher noch nicht den Arsch
in der Hose, mal in irgendeiner Form auch Widerstand zu sagen.
Klar, es gibt einzelne Stimmen, die man hört und so, die werden auch lauter
und ich glaube auch, dass diese Schock und Ohr-Methode, die die beiden da jetzt
abziehen, Trump und Musk,
in zunehmendem Maße auf, naja, ich sag mal, auf Zurückhaltung stößt.
Ja, teilweise vielleicht auch schon auf Widerstand, aber es ist halt offen,
wie resilient ist die Gesellschaft wirklich, vor allem wie resilient ist diese
Republikaner-Partei, die sich
ja einfach nur noch zum Steigbügelhalter von Wahnsinnigen gemacht hat.
Ja, ich meine bei USAID ist der Punkt, dass es sich außerdem bei der Organisation,
sie erfüllt halt mehrere Zwecke und einer der Zwecke ist aber auch ein Subventionsmechanismus
für die amerikanische Landwirtschaft,
weil USAID halt haufenweise also in nennenswertem Umfang Agrarprodukte,
Getreide von amerikanischen Farmern aufkauft und dass es halt jetzt
Auch praktisch damit kommt das zum Stillstand und da rührt sich also mittlerweile
jetzt einiges an Widerstand.
Und ja, was wir im Moment sehen, ist, dass halt auch Maßnahme um Maßnahme stückweise zurückgenommen wird.
Aber ich glaube, das ist auch Taktik so nach dem Motto oder in Kauf genommen so.
Also an dem Motto, wir versuchen jetzt erstmal 500 Prozent zu erreichen und
wenn wir am Ende bei 5 Prozent landen,
dann so sind wir da, wo wir eigentlich landen wollen.
Das Problem scheint nur zu sein, dass was so Ersparnisse angeht zum Beispiel,
was jetzt Musk's Doge hat halt jetzt veröffentlicht, dass sie jetzt 18 Milliarden
schon eingespart haben.
Nur um dann halt jetzt das komplett revidieren zu müssen und jetzt eher bei
ein paar hundert Millionen liegen an Ersparnissen,
weil sie unter anderem Milliarden mit Millionen verwechselt hatten an einer
Stelle und Dinge reingenommen haben.
Einen großen Vertrag, den allerdings Biden schon gecancelt hatte.
Der tauchte dann bei Doge auch nochmal auf in der vorläufigen Erfolgsbilanz.
Und wenn man jetzt wahrscheinlich dagegen rechnen würde, wie viele Produktivitätsverluste
in US-Behörden jetzt diese Aktionen von Musk verursacht haben,
dann kommt am Ende wahrscheinlich eher eine negative Bilanz dabei raus.
Also wirklich gespart wird da gerade offenbar nichts.
Es geht scheinbar auch darum, einfach Mittel umschichten zu wollen.
Und ja, da wo es am Ende landet, ist unklar.
Unklar, aber auf jeden Fall, wie gesagt, zum Beispiel 70.000 Mitarbeiter wohl
im öffentlichen Dienst haben auf die erste Droh-E-Mail ihren Rücktritt erklärt.
Also gesagt, sie nehmen das Angebot an und scheiden aus dem öffentlichen Dienst aus.
Macht euren Scheiß alleine.
Das Angebot war, dass sie bis September weiterbezahlt werden und ab sofort nicht
mehr arbeiten müssen und aber weiterhin Geld kriegen.
Das hat aber auch nicht für alle funktioniert. Ein paar Mitarbeiter mussten
dann feststellen, die darauf geklickt haben,
dass ihr Rücktritt abgelehnt wurde und sie stattdessen einfach entlassen wurden, ohne Bezüge.
Ja,
wenn man kein funktionierendes Rechtssystem mehr hat, dann läuft das halt irgendwie so.
Ja, und die Folgen natürlich jetzt von auch was wir vorher hatten mit den Zöllen.
Ich meine, wirtschaftlich sind die USA extrem stark. Also sie sind unter beiden
relativ gut im Vergleich mit anderen Ländern weltweit aus den Krisen rausgekommen.
Also insbesondere Covid und dann eben steigende Energiepreise und Ukraine-Krieg und so.
Aber der Ausblick verschlechtert sich halt permanent und die innenpolitische
Unzufriedenheit steigt.
Trumps Popularität sinkt schneller als erwartet und als in seiner ersten Amtszeit.
Er hat für einen Präsidenten, der die Wahl gewonnen hat, schon mal mit relativ
niedriger Zustimmung begonnen.
Es war eigentlich ein eher knapper Sieg, also knapper als Biden zum Beispiel
gewonnen hat. Also Biden hatte wesentlich höheren Vorsprung in der letzten Wahl
als Trump jetzt gegenüber Harris.
Insofern war es jetzt auch kein Erdrutschsieg, den er hatte.
Und seitdem ist die Zustimmung massiv runtergegangen und auch die Zustimmung
in vielen seiner Kernpolitikfelder ist nicht gut.
Also insbesondere nehmen die Russen, nehmen die Amerikaner ihm nicht ab,
dass die Russen oder Putin jetzt irgendwie Freunde sein sollen.
Das schlucken die Amerikaner nicht, zum größten Teil.
Und dann...
Hat er ja versprochen, dass Dinge billiger werden, was natürlich von herein
Quatsch war, was nicht sein kann, weil dann hätten wir Deflation und Deflation
ist wirtschaftlich einfach ein komplettes Desaster.
Das Einzige, was passieren könnte, ist, dass eben Beschäftigung und Einkommen
sehr stark in die Höhe gehen und die Inflation weiter runter geht.
Tatsächlich passiert aber eher das Gegenteil.
Also Beschäftigung und Einkommen gehen nicht wesentlich nach oben.
Und die Inflationsrate, gerade letzte Zahlen von heute, ist wieder leicht angestiegen in den USA.
Und ja, wie weit das jetzt runtergeht.
Also ursprünglich hatte man angenommen, dass Trump diesmal die ganzen Dinger
durchzieht, bis im Sommer oder
im Herbst dann sich die Auswirkungen zeigen und dann halt Schluss ist.
Aber jetzt im Moment sieht es so aus, als wenn sich Gegenbewegung schneller
entwickelt, als das auch erwartet wurde.
Und Trump ist nicht gut im Bilden von Allianzen und hat sich sehr viele Feinde geschaffen.
Ja, vor allem unter seinen eigenen Wählern, weil natürlich viele davon jetzt
auch von den Entlassungen betroffen sind.
Wir hatten das schon erwähnt, USAID, der Ausfall, aber auch so die Drohung der
Zölle mit den Kanadiern, das sind ja dann wichtige Düngemittel,
die zum Beispiel die US-amerikanischen Bauern aus Kanada beziehen,
wodurch halt sozusagen das Bestellen der Felder nochmal sehr viel teurer wird.
Also es gibt so viele kleine Bereiche, wo es dann eben doch die Leute trifft
und man kann nur hoffen, dass sie dann eben am Geld dann doch merken,
dass sie beschissen worden sind.
Ich denke mal, das Reality-Distortion-Field wird insgesamt noch eine Weile halten.
Trotzdem stimmt schon, es gibt da wenig zu feiern und am Ende,
wenn die Leute da die Bilanz aufmachen, müssten sie, ich weiß nicht,
ob sie es werden, Aber müssten sie ja eigentlich feststellen,
dass eigentlich nichts von dem eingetroffen ist, was angekündigt worden ist.
Und das ist natürlich ein Thema.
Und das war jetzt ja nur die innenpolitische Folgenliste.
Ja, also Trump hat halt natürlich völlig unrealistische Versprechungen gemacht,
aber viele seiner Wähler wussten, dass das Übertreibungen sind.
Aber sie haben halt nicht gedacht, dass jetzt okay, das ist jetzt alles,
dass er die Probleme gleich am ersten Tag oder in der ersten Woche löst.
Aber so ein, zwei Monate sollten doch schon reichen dafür.
So ist bei vielen seiner Anhänger, also die sind jetzt dann auch wiederum nicht
so geduldig, sondern die wollen halt schon einfach,
dass sich die Dinge ändern und,
Propaganda hat an bestimmten Stellen einfach ihre Grenzen.
Wenn die Leute merken, dass sie kein Geld in der Tasche haben,
dann kannst du da einfach und andere offensichtlich in Saus und Braus leben,
dann kannst du da noch so viel Propaganda draufwerfen.
Dann musst du mit Unterdrückung dann kommen.
Das ist dann halt die nächste Stufe und das ist halt natürlich etwas, was auch droht.
Von daher muss man sich nicht wundern, wenn das Militär geschwächt wird und so weiter.
Also das sind alles, ich bin mir einfach nicht ganz so sicher,
wie viel wirklich geplante Agenda da drin ist von irgendwelchen anderen Leuten,
also die natürlich jetzt nicht,
Trump hat sich das so nicht ausgedacht, der führt das letzten Endes auch nur
so aus, was ihm so irgendwie gerade erzählt wird und will halt die ganze Zeit
einfach nur groß dastehen und irgendwie den Mafia-Boss mimen.
Und um ihn herum ist halt so ein Ring von Hardcore- Leuten,
die eben in dieser ganzen Konstellation für sich eine Gelegenheit sehen,
irgendwie das Maximale abzuziehen und dabei stören natürlich juristische Verfolgung
und Überprüfer und Regeln und,
Regulatorien, die stören einfach
nur und deswegen wird da das Gewitter losgelassen auf diese ganzen Dinge.
Und inwiefern die Wähler überhaupt nochmal eine Chance haben werden,
hier in irgendeiner Form zu antworten, wird sich zeigen.
Ich warte ja nur darauf, bis sie dann halt auch noch auf die Wahlsysteme gehen.
Ja, ich meine, das ist natürlich klar. Das ist auch Versuch.
Versuch ist auch, die freie Presse auszuschalten.
Also es gibt wohl verschiedene Verfahren jetzt unter dem neuen,
auch von Trump eingesetzten Chef, der hier FTC,
die unter anderem eben auch Sendelizenzen vergibt.
Und die möchten gerne unter anderem den großen amerikanischen Fernsehsendern
wie CNN und NBC und so weiter gerne ihre Sendelizenz entziehen.
So angeblich wegen genau linker Propaganda.
Wie man das macht in der Sowjetunion.
Genau. Allerdings so, und da warte ich die ganze Zeit drauf,
was sie noch nicht gemacht haben, ist jetzt, Leute zu verhaften und in den Knast
zu werfen, zum Beispiel.
Naja, nach einem Monat ist jetzt vielleicht auch ein bisschen viel verlangt, oder?
Ja, aber bei vielen Dingen sind die praktischen Auswirkungen,
also sie haben auch jetzt die Militärhilfen-Lieferungen an die Ukraine nicht
gestoppt, zum Beispiel,
und sie sind auch nicht aus der NATO ausgetreten.
Und ja, also viel von dem ist, also an konkreten Dingen ist jetzt in der Luft.
Also das Konkreteste ist jetzt USAID und das was innenpolitisch mit den Entlassungen
und so. Aber selbst das wird halt teilweise zurückgerollt jetzt.
Aber was noch fehlt oder was noch nicht passiert ist, ist sozusagen,
sie haben noch keinen inciting incident, wie es so schön heißt,
so im Drehbuchschreiben.
Also es gab noch keinen George Floyd,
keinen Vorfall, der für sich genommen so mobilisierend ist,
dass halt jetzt Massenproteste ausbrechen.
Aber das ist aus meiner Sicht nur eine Frage der Zeit, bis es dazu kommen wird
und wir werden Proteste sehen in Kürze.
Erste haben sich schon formiert und gerade auch einige republikanische Abgeordnete
wurden von ihren Wählern in ihren Wahlkreisen auch ziemlich hart drangenommen, ausgebuht.
Ziemlich niedergemacht.
Wegen eben vieler Dinge, die jetzt passiert sind.
Und ja, das läuft halt alles nicht so gut.
Also die Begeisterung für Trumps Politik hält sich in Grenzen.
Ja, hält sich in Grenzen, aber er hat auch noch bestimmte Grenzen noch nicht
unterschritten. Also das wird noch eine Weile dauern.
Um vielleicht mal den Teil der Folgen, die das bisherige Verhalten für die USA hat, abzurunden,
muss man natürlich noch erwähnen, dass es hier nicht nur innenpolitischen Schaden
gegeben hat, sondern natürlich auch außenpolitisch schweren Schaden gegeben hat.
Also das ist natürlich, du hast ja auch einen längeren Tweet dazu geschrieben
auf Mastodon, Tweet auf Mastodon, ich sag Tweet.
Das ist ein Tweet. Ja.
Ich ganz interessant fand, dass halt einfach der schwere Schaden auch schon
angerichtet ist und dass er auch in gewisser Hinsicht irreversibel ist.
Also dass das, was jetzt an Vertrauen zerstört worden ist, den USA noch sehr lange nachhängen wird.
Je nachdem, wie sich das noch verschlimmert. Aber selbst wenn es jetzt so bliebe,
ist im Prinzip das Vertrauen in die USA als Schutzmacht weitgehend dahin in der EU geht die Angst um,
und das wird natürlich auch bei allen anderen Konflikten weltweit eine Rolle spielen.
Ja und natürlich Trumps Glaubwürdigkeit ist auch bereits massiv angeschlagen.
Wenn es die überhaupt gab jemals, also ich weiß nicht.
Ja, naja sagen wir mal so,
In seine zweite Amtszeit ist er jetzt reingegangen mit einem gewissen Vertrauensvorschuss
bei der Reihe von Leuten,
die das Vertrauen hatten, dass er Dinge zum Positiven wenden kann.
Aber,
Was wir halt sehen, ist, dass er selbst, also auf der einen Seite ist es natürlich,
kann man sagen, super Strategie, super Erfolg,
die Presse und die Opposition mit
eben diesem Tornado an Verordnungen und skandalösen Dingen zu überfluten.
Und dadurch alleine nur, indem sie so viele Dinge tun,
dass man gar nicht dazu kommt, sich ausreichend zu empören und aufzuregen über
die ganzen Dinge, weil es einfach zu viel ist.
Aber gleichzeitig führt das natürlich dazu,
dass es eben auch keinen Fokus gibt bei den Dingen, dass eigentlich eins nach
dem anderen nicht umgesetzt, nicht durchgesetzt,
zurückgedreht, nicht eingehalten wird und dass Trump selbst komplett am Flipfloppen ist.
Das heißt, welchen Vertrag auch immer du mit ihm schließt, musst du davon ausgehen,
dass das nur eine vorübergehende Vereinbarung ist.
Und wenn natürlich Dinge Investitionen beinhalten,
wo eine Partei erstmal Dinge auf den Tisch legen muss und ich mich dann aber
auf Zusagen nicht verlassen kann, dann investiere ich nicht.
Und das gilt jetzt nicht nur für Finanzinvestitionen, sondern auch für Friedensinvestitionen
oder Rüstungsinvestitionen.
Ein Beispiel haben wir ja schon
genannt. Seine Ankündigung von Strafzöllen gegenüber Kanada und Mexiko,
das sind die beiden Länder, wo er während seiner Amtszeit eine Neufassung des
NAFTA-Vertrages, also der nordamerikanischen Freihandelszohle,
ja schon durchgeführt hat.
Er selber hat mit denen einen Vertrag ausgehandelt, an den die sich halten und
jetzt kommt er an und sagt so, ja nee, machen wir aber anders,
hier gibt es jetzt Strafzölle, was halt im Prinzip gegen den Sinn dieses Vertrags ist.
Und das führt natürlich dazu, dass niemand mehr in irgendeiner Form glaubt,
dass man irgendwas mit ihm, wenn man noch richtig im Kopf ist,
irgendwie verhandeln kann.
Das werden wir dann auch nochmal diskutieren, denke ich, wenn wir auf die Ukraine
zu sprechen kommen, die wir jetzt ein bisschen rausgenommen haben,
weil heute geht es wirklich primär um die USA.
Ein anderer Punkt, wo bereits Schaden entstanden ist und wo man auch abwarten
wird, wie sich das entwickelt.
Aber USA sind halt weltgrößte Waffenexporteur.
Und die Frage natürlich in dem Moment,
wo jetzt auch das Bündnis in Frage steht und Trump so am Rumeiern ist.
Die Frage steht, wie sehr können wir uns denn auf die USA und auf amerikanische
Waffen prinzipiell verlassen.
Also erstmal nicht nur, dass sie auch geliefert werden, sodass also bestehende
Verträge eingehalten werden, sondern viele der US-Waffen sind halt natürlich
echte Hightech-Waffen zu Patriot.
Aber gerade die F-35, die sich
bei den alliierten NATO-Kräften jetzt zum Verkaufsschlager entwickelt hat.
Die meisten Länder haben die F-35 mit der US-Elektronik bestellt.
Und die US-Elektronik braucht halt die Lockheed-Cloud,
um gewartet zu werden, um Software-Updates einzuspielen, um Diagnosen,
durchzuführen, um festzustellen, welche Teile sind jetzt abgelaufen,
um, wenn du jetzt Elektronik ersetzt, um dann quasi wieder das DRM und die ganze
Krypto, ja, wie bei John Deere im Prinzip mit den Traktoren, so ähm.
Die USA kontrolliert halt die Elektronik in den F-35 mit zwei Ausnahmen.
UK und Israel.
Beide Länder statten die F-35 mit heimischer Elektronik aus.
Aus Gründen.
So und die Frage, die sich natürlich jetzt manche Leute stellen ist,
okay, was ist, wenn wir jetzt in einen Konflikt mit Russland kommen und Russland
und Putin sind beste Buddies oder USA hat jetzt Angst davor,
was Russland denn tun könnte, wenn wir mit F-35 jetzt Ziele in Russland angreifen
und uns dann sagt, also wenn ihr jetzt unsere F-35 benutzt,
um jetzt Ziele in Russland anzugreifen,
so schalten wir euch von Software-Updates ab oder schalten die Flugzeuge komplett ab.
Selbst das, ich meine, ich glaube nicht, dass sie das tun werden.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass es jetzt einen Remote-Kill-Switch gibt.
Aber natürlich, wenn du die Software-Updates einspielst, kannst du natürlich
jederzeit mit jedem Software-Update einen Remote-Kill-Switch installieren, sogar wenn du willst.
Aber der Punkt ist, selbst wenn du es nicht hast, kannst du halt die Schlotte
nicht am Fliegen halten, so richtig.
Überdauere, weil dir einfach die Tools fehlen. Und ja, und das gilt für eine
Reihe von Waffensystemen, wo sich jetzt die Leute die Frage stellen, okay, was machen wir?
Trump hat ja auch angedeutet, dass er unter Umständen Indien die F-35 zum Kauf
anbieten würde. Das ist natürlich auch super delikat.
Indien ist ja bisher eigentlich sehr bekannt dafür.
Um sich eigentlich aus den Blöcken mal so ein bisschen rauszuhalten.
Das haben wir ja auch im Ukraine-Konflikt gesehen.
Und militärisch wiederum ist aber Indien sehr mit Russland verbunden.
Also ein Großteil des Militärs, wenn nicht sogar das meiste,
ist halt russische Technik.
Man muss halt immer verstehen, und das zeigt ja auch das Beispiel hier,
was du gerade genannt hast, wenn man halt Waffensysteme aus anderen Ländern
kauft, dann bindet man sich in gewisser Hinsicht auch an diese Länder.
Weil da ist einfach das Interesse groß und der Zugang, den Russland zu Indien hat, der ist halt groß.
Die F-35 ist aber nun wirklich das schärfste Schwert im derzeitigen Kriegsarsenal.
Es ist ja nicht irgendein Kampfflugzeug, sondern es ist einfach das fähigste,
modernste, derzeit im Einsatz befindliche Kampfflugzeug, was auch in ausreichenden Mengen gebaut wird.
Es hat halt diese Stealth-Möglichkeit, also es ist sehr, sehr,
sehr schwer von Radarsystemen erfasst zu werden.
Und man hat das eben jetzt wunderbar gesehen bei dem Einsatz,
den Israel gegen den Iran geflogen hat.
Ja, also der Iran hat sich da quasi gegen diese Flugzeuge überhaupt nicht wehren können.
Und wenn jetzt die USA Indien F-35 bereitstellt,
dann geht natürlich sofort die Angst um, dass die Russen hier so viel Zugang
haben, weil einfach Indien jetzt nicht in der Kategorie treuer langjähriger Partner der USA,
der irgendwie international immer im Gleichschrittmarsch unterwegs ist,
wie die NATO-Mitglieder oder andere Verbündete wie Südkorea.
Also ich weiß nicht, Südkorea hat jetzt glaube ich keine F-35,
das war jetzt ein Beispiel für, doch stimmt, die haben sogar auch die F-35 gerade.
Und bei Indien würde man halt dann auch befürchten, dass eben Details über die
F-35 liegen an die Russen.
Und damit gefährden sie sozusagen ihr komplettes Waffensystem.
Also dann ist einfach das ganze Vertrauen weg.
Also dass die F-16 kaufen oder so etwas, das kann man sich durchaus vorstellen.
Das ist ja, sagen wir mal, vielleicht auch im Interesse des Westens,
hier sozusagen Indien auch so ein bisschen in die eigene Sicherheitssphäre mit reinzuziehen.
Aber eben vielleicht nicht gleich vom Staat weg mit dem absoluten Top-Waffen,
mit denen halt einfach nur die treuesten Verbündeten ausgerüstet werden.
Also UK, Italien, Niederlande, Australien, Norwegen, Dänemark,
Japan, Israel, Südkorea, Belgien.
Das sind die Länder, die derzeit F-35 haben.
Und Finnland, Polen, Kanada, Schweiz,
Singapur interessanterweise, Griechenland, Rumänien, Tschechien,
die überlegen das und Deutschland angeblich auch. Aber das sind natürlich lange Wege.
Viele europäische Länder haben bestellt, aber viel wurde, also der Großteil
wurde noch nicht geliefert.
Polen hat auch eine Menge bestellt und so.
Und ja, wahrscheinlich,
also das Mindeste, was jetzt wahrscheinlich Europa machen wird, ist,
seine unabhängigen Wartungsmöglichkeiten und Ersatzteilproduktion ins Land zu holen.
Was teilweise ohnehin geplant ist, aber das wird halt das Minimum sein.
Des Weiteren wird wahrscheinlich jetzt die Tendenz größer werden,
einfach innereuropäisch zu beschaffen.
Also Tschechien zum Beispiel kauft auch die Gripen von Schweden.
Die scheint zumindest, sie scheint auch, ich meine es ist keine F-35.
Aber es ist trotzdem ein modernes, sehr fähiges Kampfflugzeug,
was ein bisschen billiger ist als die F-35.
Interessanterweise gar nicht so viel billiger in der Anschaffung,
aber einen Bruchteil im Betrieb kostet.
Also ein Problem mit der F-35 ist, dass sie mittlerweile so 20.000 bis 30.000
Dollar pro Flugstunde kostet,
während du bei der Gripen mit irgendwie 3.000 bis 6.000 Dollar pro Flugstunde mit dabei bist. Und.
Es gibt halt auch den Trend, Stealth mehr durch elektronische Kampfführung zu ersetzen,
dem man einfach sagt, es ist uns egal, ob wir irgendwie Radar reflektieren oder nicht.
Wir hauen einfach so viel Leistung im Spektrum drauf.
Hauptsache, die können keinen Fix kriegen.
Und es ist eh so, dass ja auch Stealth nicht bedeutet, dass du unsichtbar bist,
sondern Stealth bedeutet.
Dass du näher ran kannst an die Radarstellungen,
bevor sie einen Lock kriegen und dass du anfliegenden Raketen besser ausweichen kannst,
weil der Signalrauschabstand schlechter ist, aber die sind halt nicht unsichtbar.
Und Anti-Stats-Technologie nimmt natürlich auch zu.
Und das wäre auch, sagen wir, die größte Gefahr wahrscheinlich,
wenn jetzt Indien die Dinger hat, so dass dann die Russen auch beispielsweise Tests machen könnten,
wie gut oder die Informationen kriegen, wie sie denn jetzt ihre Radar einstellen
müssen und auf welchen Frequenzen und aus welchen Richtungen und so.
Die die M35 am besten anpeilen können und so.
Das ist halt nicht unbedingt hilfreich.
Ja, also insofern denke ich,
da kommen wir dann jetzt, wenn wir jetzt für die Folgen für Europa kommen,
wird halt potenziell eine Folge dann umgekehrt für Europa sein,
dass Europa seine Rüstungsindustrie ausbaut.
Ja, dann lass uns doch mal zu den Folgen für Europa und die Welt kommen.
Denn das, was in den USA abgeht, hat natürlich enorme Schockwellen ausgelöst,
eben nicht nur in den USA, sondern eben auch in der EU und Europa generell.
Wir werden natürlich auch noch über die Ukraine sprechen.
Und tja, was kann man dazu sagen?
Im Prinzip hat die USA diese Stellung als Führer der freien Welt,
wie man so schön immer sagt, die hat Trump eigentlich bereits verspielt,
weil so verhält man sich halt nicht als Führer der freien Welt.
Also, die NATO ist massiv geschwächt, kann man sagen,
allein nur durch die verbalen Ansagen, die Trump gemacht hat.
Nämlich zu sagen, ja, also ob wir euch beistehen oder nicht,
das müssen wir dann erstmal sehen, wenn ihr angegriffen werdet.
Und zusammen mit eben der anderen langen Liste an Zelensky ist ein Diktator
und sein Anrankuscheln an Putin hat jetzt dazu geführt,
dass die NATO-Existenz an sich infrage gestellt ist.
Also auch Kanzler Merz hat gesagt und andere auch,
wir werden sehen, ob wir im Sommer zum nächsten NATO-Gipfel im Juni oder so
noch überhaupt eine NATO haben, so ungefähr.
Das hat Merz gesagt.
Also die Zukunft der NATO steht im Moment komplett in Frage,
vor allem weil die NATO ja ursprünglich in so eine US-amerikanische Veranstaltung gewesen ist.
Also das haben die USA ja erfunden.
Ja, das dreht sich ja eigentlich auch alles um die USA. Es gibt auch immer diese
Regelung, so ein NATO-Generalsekretär stellt ein Europäer, aber die militärische
Führung geht natürlich immer von den USA aus.
Also es steht sozusagen überhaupt gar nicht zur Disposition,
dass es irgendjemand anderes ist als die USA. Von daher ist es halt schon immer
ein USA und seine Vasallen sozusagen, womit ja eigentlich auch alle wunderbar gefahren sind.
Das war natürlich jetzt im Rückblick gesehen sicherlich auch ein Fehler,
dass man sich zu sehr auf die militärische Stärke verlassen hat der USA und
eben auch ihre uneingeschränkte Bereitschaft überall ihre Macht und ihre Vormachtstellung
und ihre Definitionsmacht in der Hinsicht auch klar in den Vordergrund zu stellen.
Weil es ja im Interesse der USA war.
Letztlich handelt die Trump-Regierung klar gegen ihre eigenen Interessen.
Das will er natürlich nicht wahrhaben oder es ist nichts, worüber er nachdenkt
oder begreift es nicht. Man weiß es nicht.
Tatsache ist, die USA sind gerade bereit, einen Großteil ihrer Gewinne sozusagen,
also ihrer außenpolitischen, weltpolitischen Gewinne, die sie gemacht haben
durch die NATO und durch ihre ganze Handelsstruktur und so weiter der letzten 50,
80, 100 Jahre komplett über Bord zu werfen.
Ja, bemerkenswert ist auch, dass eigentlich die Politik der USA in der Vergangenheit
darauf ausgerichtet war, zu verhindern, dass Europa zu einig und zu stark wird.
Das heißt, es war eigentlich auch im Sinne der USA dieser Deal nach dem Motto, okay,
macht mal, also ihr dürft zwar mithelfen bei der Verteidigung,
aber bitte nicht so viel, dass im Zweifelsfall ihr uns irgendwie die Führung streitig machen könnt.
Das heißt, bislang hat die USA eher versucht, Europa klein und schwach zu halten.
Und das, was Trump jetzt tut, könnte zumindest, was es militärisch angeht,
könnte jetzt zum genauen Gegenteil führen.
Nämlich, dass Europa jetzt seine Militärausgaben massiv erhöht,
seine Rüstungsindustrie massiv ausbaut.
Damit gleichzeitig auch den USA die Vorherrschaft, also was vom Exportmarkt
sicherlich noch mehr abnimmt.
Aber vor allen Dingen dann eben sich zu einem gleichwertigen Akteur auf der
internationalen Lüne entwickeln könnte, langfristig.
Oder auch Kontrahenten der USA.
Absolut, weil ich meine, ich weiß nicht, ob wir das schon mal hier hatten,
aber es ist ja im Prinzip so, die USA stellt es viel Hightech her,
aber das macht Europa auch.
Und wenn man mal alle Waffentechnologien nimmt, die so in Europa im Angebot
sind, es gibt nicht viele Waffentechnologien,
wo die USA irgendwas haben, was die Europäer so nicht haben.
Vielleicht jetzt nicht genauso, das Patriot System hat jetzt nicht so ein unmittelbares
Äquivalent, trotzdem werden sehr viele sehr gute Luftabwehrsysteme auch in Europa
hergestellt, auch in Deutschland hatten wir ja auch schon sehr.
Iris-T-System. Für andere Anwendungsbereiche und andere Strecken und andere
Fälle und so weiter. Aber die Technologie ist da.
Flugzeuge, die Technologie ist da.
Im Bereich von Artillerie ist Europa sogar führend, also vor allem Deutschland.
Da kann man irgendwie mithalten. Man hat gepanzerte Fahrzeuge,
man hat im Prinzip alles, was sozusagen die militärischen Anforderungen heutzutage
sind, hat man auch in Hightech.
Und es ist halt nur eine Frage der Kapazitäten und der.
Industriehaftigkeit. Man muss halt teilweise weg von Manufaktur hin zu industrieller
Produktion von bestimmten Systemen, um eben hier in irgendeiner Form noch mithalten zu können.
Das ist nichts, was man sich jetzt gewünscht hat in Europa. Und ich sehe auch
jetzt gerade in Deutschland da eine schwierige Debatte aufkommen.
Das ist ja noch gar nicht so lange her, wo wir dann überhaupt erstmal unser
Selbstverständnis überarbeitet haben bezüglich internationaler Konflikte,
Beteiligung, Waffenlieferung etc.
Und jetzt wieder so in kurzer Zeit, obwohl alle so friedensverliebt waren und
dachten, das wird jetzt bis in alle Ewigkeit so weitergehen,
umzuschalten auf eine Militärproduktion und einen entsprechenden Etat.
Das ist natürlich hart, aber ehrlich gesagt, ich sehe in der aktuellen Situation
wenig Alternativen, wenn man jetzt nicht anfängt, schnell nachvollziehbar ein
entsprechendes Bedrohungspotenzial aufzubauen.
Von nichts anderem wird sich halt Russland irgendwie nennenswert beeindrucken lassen.
Und das ist natürlich dann eben für die USA auch ein Problem,
weil da wo sie bisher ihre Technologie hätten verkaufen können,
da wird dann halt nicht zugegriffen werden.
Das wird sicherlich auch die Ukraine so sehen und die Ukraine wird selber natürlich
auch ein großer Waffenproduktion werden, also irgendwann auch mal im Export,
derzeit natürlich nicht.
Und ja, ein weiterer Punkt, aber das bedeutet aber natürlich jetzt vor allem für Europa,
Europa muss aufwachen in dieser Hinsicht und muss da auch eine neue Rolle einnehmen
und man muss sich halt auch fragen,
inwiefern es einen Nachfolger der NATO braucht oder eine europäische NATO,
die eben auch schlagkräftig sein kann ohne die USA.
Ja, also da hat das Nachdenken tatsächlich auch schon begonnen,
nämlich wie könnte ein europäisches Verteidigungsbündnis aussehen.
Da laufen bereits Debatten.
Einerseits könnte vieles über die EU-Ebene laufen und wird wahrscheinlich auch
über die EU-Ebene laufen.
Das führt dann aber zu den Sonderfällen Türkei, Norwegen und UK,
die nicht in der EU sind, aber in Europa,
wo es jeweils ganz andere dann Arrangements eventuell geben müsste,
weil natürlich so ein, ja,
also europäisches Verteidigungsbündnis ist ein Schritt.
Aber der nächste Schritt wäre dann der, wo auch überlegt wird,
eine europäische Armee zu schaffen.
Und das hätte wiederum den Vorteil,
dass man ein einheitliches Kommando hätte und sowas wie eben strategische Autonomie
hätte und nicht jedes Mal 23 Länder unbedingt zustimmen müssen.
Man könnte das Ganze besser koordinieren, aber wahrscheinlich der größte Vorteil
wäre, dass die Finanzierung unter Umständen einfacher sein könnte.
Und wir sind da ohnehin auf dem Weg in eine föderativere EU.
Und das könnte halt in einer eben dann auch Föderation münden.
Das Mindeste, was das bedeuten würde, wäre, dass die EU selber Steuern erheben kann.
Das heißt, man würde sich irgendwas überlegen, was weiß ich,
irgendeine Verbrauchssteuer oder irgendwas, wie auch immer.
Und die würde dann von einer EU erhoben und so könnten daneben gemeinsame Projekte
finanziert werden, aber auch gemeinsame Schulden aufgenommen werden.
Wobei man das ja schon gemacht hat für Corona, hat die EU irgendwie 600 Milliarden
an Schulden aufgenommen, wo
im Moment auch noch unklar ist, wie die denn jetzt zurückgezahlt werden.
Weil aus dem laufenden EU-Haushalt lässt sich das nämlich nicht zurückzahlen.
Und insofern wird ohnehin jetzt erwogen, das eventuell über eine EU-Steuer zu machen.
Das würde dann aber wiederum weiteren Rattenschwanz lostreten und eben dann
am Ende wir so etwas wie eine EU-Regierung tatsächlich hätten,
die dann über den EU-Haushalt entscheidet und eigene Mittel und Finanzen hat.
Also das ist jetzt eine Richtung, die losgetreten wurde.
Es könnte aber auch sein, dass sich Europa komplett zerstreitet und dass Trump es irgendwie schafft,
die Europäer auseinanderzudividieren und dann jeder irgendwie seins macht.
Aber im Moment ist klar, dass Europa...
Mehr machen muss und Europa sich mehr auf sich zurückbesinnen muss.
Und du hast vollkommen recht.
Waffenmäßig ist auch alles da. Technologiemäßig ist alles da.
Insofern, es fehlt nur an Zeit, Motivation und dem Willen.
Aber da hat Trump jetzt eben auch seinen Beitrag zu geleistet,
dass jetzt möglicherweise Dinge auf einmal denkbar werden, die vor ein paar
Jahren, wo jeder gesagt hätte, das ist vollkommen irrsinnig.
Ich meine, was so dieses so jetzt geht's los Moment betrifft in Europa,
da hatte man ja nun oft schon Hoffnung und zu oft ist es dann halt dann doch
wieder nichts geworden,
weil am Ende alles im kleinen, kleinen nationaler Interessen zerrieben wurde.
Da gibt es ja viele Beispiele, auch die Weltraumindustrie ist in Europa nicht
besonders kompetitiv und ausgerechnet Elon Musk hat sozusagen ihnen irgendwie
mal den Stinkefinger gezeigt und jetzt stehen sie halt doof da und das Ganze ist halt nicht nur,
aber auch eine Folge des ganzen Hin und Heres immer zwischen Deutschland und Frankreich,
die sich immer nicht so richtig auf irgendwas einigen können,
weil jeder will natürlich seine eigenen Pfünde nicht abgeben.
Ich lenke jetzt so ein bisschen ab, aber ich denke, das zeigt so, wo das Problem ist.
Mal ganz abgesehen von so potenziellen Problematiken wie Ungarn,
Slowenien, Österreich,
also dieser Bereich der EU,
die halt auch noch sehr starke Bindungen an Russland haben, was so Energieversorgung
betrifft oder im Falle von der Orbán-Regierung oder eben auch der FPÖ.
Dann eben auch konkrete Verbindungen direkt zu Putins Regime haben.
Das kann man ja natürlich nicht anders sagen.
Aber ich denke insgesamt ist der Mehrheitskonsens schon da, dass man was tun
will, aber ich bin so ein bisschen im Zweifel, ob wir schon genug Momentum haben.
Aber die Angst geht natürlich jetzt langsam um.
Auch die Angst, dass man keine Zeit mehr hat und dass eben jetzt was getan werden
muss und dass nicht nur irgendwas Theoretisches ist, mit dem man sich mal in
der Zukunft beschäftigen muss, sondern was halt einfach im Prinzip schon gestern
hätte stattfinden müssen.
Ja,
mein anderer Aspekt, der jetzt schon auch hochgepoppt ist und den wir auch schon
mal angekündigt hatten, dass das passieren könnte,
ist, dass sowas wie Run auf eigene Atomwaffen begonnen hat.
Und das Ding ist, dass ja Deutschland, Belgien, Italien,
Niederlande und die Türkei im Rahmen der sogenannten nuklearen Teilhabe US-Atomwaffen
im Land haben, die unter gemeinsamer Kontrolle stehen.
Das heißt, wo die Regel die ist, dass einem Einsatz dieser Waffen das Gastland
und die USA zustimmen muss.
Und das Ganze wurde halt ursprünglich auch initiiert, um eben Länder wie Deutschland
davon abzuhalten, sich eigene Atomwaffen zuzulegen.
Weil da war, also Franz Josef Strauß hatte seinerzeit, wollte unbedingt,
dass Deutschland sich atomar auch bewaffnet und sagen, die nukleare Teilhabe war halt ein Teil davon.
Ja und im Moment haben eben nur Frankreich und Großbritannien Atomwaffen,
so in der Größenordnung von 200 Sprengköpfen beide.
Also ich glaube ein Zwanzigstel von dem, was USA und Sowjetunion je haben. Aber es reicht.
Und es sind alles strategische Atomwaffen, keine taktischen.
Also die sind mehr so Waffen,
nicht als Ersatz für herkömmliche Waffen,
also für konventionelle Waffen, sondern das sind halt die großen Dinger im Megaton-Bereich,
die dann ganze Städte auf einmal annihilieren.
Das ist die...
Art der Waffen. Ja, und die Frage ist jetzt so,
was ist jetzt mit dem Abschreckungswert dieser Waffen unter Trump im Moment?
Also irgendwo zwischen Null und irgendwas.
Aber auf jeden Fall unklar. Unklar.
Und gut praktisch sind die Waffen ohnehin unter US-Kontrolle.
Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass wir jetzt sagen könnten, hier,
wir reißen uns jetzt mit Waffengewalt unter Nagel.
Und tatsächlich hat sich Merz auch bereits in dieser Hinsicht geäußert und nämlich
Gespräche mit Frankreich über eine nukleare Teilhabe zu führen.
Das ist sozusagen der Beginn. Und die andere Sache ist, dass sowieso die französischen
Atomraketen ohnehin von deutschen Firmen gebaut werden.
Nur die Sprengköpfe sind französisch. Ja.
Also die Trägerraketen haben wir sozusagen schon. Ja, so.
Und das ist natürlich jetzt alles überhaupt nicht lustig, weil natürlich in
dem Moment, wo jetzt Deutschland und Europa anfängt, über eigene Atomwaffen nachzudenken,
werden natürlich dann Länder wie Japan,
Südkorea, Taiwan und wahrscheinlich so 20, 30 andere Länder auf dieser Welt sich auch sagen.
Okay, wenn es keine US-Ordnungsmacht gibt und wir uns nicht erpressen lassen wollen.
Nordkorea hat es vorgemacht.
Ja,
wir brauchen einfach auch 50 oder 100 Atomsprengköpfe und das ist auch nicht
so eine technologische Hürde, das zu tun.
Auch die Ukraine gehört natürlich in diese Liste rein.
Ja, und die Ukraine gehört da genauso rein, ja.
Aber auch Länder wie Tschechien oder vielleicht sogar Rumänien wären in der
Lage, innerhalb von Monaten eigene Atomwaffen zu bauen.
So und ja, das alles sind jetzt potenzielle Folgen, in die sich die Welt gerade entwickelt.
So,
ich meine, ein anderes Gerücht,
was ich noch gehört habe, ist, dass Trump eigentlich einen ganz großen Plan
hatte und im großen Stil möchte, dass die USA und Russland abrüsten.
So und da ist dann natürlich die Frage wie denn dann europäische Aufrüstung
in dieses ganze Ding auch hineinpasst,
das macht also auch alles irgendwie gerade überhaupt keinen Sinn, was da vor sich geht.
Ja jetzt haben wir die Folgen für Europa und die spezielle Geschichte mit Atomwaffen gemacht.
Schauen wir mal nochmal, was es jetzt für Deutschland eigentlich konkret bedeutet,
diese aktuelle Situation.
Also jetzt haben wir ja die neue Regierung, also wir haben sie natürlich jetzt
noch nicht, aber es ist gewählt worden und ich weiß nicht, haben wir überhaupt
schon gesagt, was für heute für ein Datum ist, ich glaube ich habe es mal wieder vergessen,
ich bin nicht so ein unprofessioneller Podcaster, ist zum Heulen, 26.
Februar 2025. Die Wahl war jetzt letzten Sonntag vor drei Tagen und ja, es sieht halt,
danach aus, dass wir wieder eine sogenannte Große Koalition bekommen werden,
also CDU-geführte Koalition mit der SPD.
Da wissen wir dann auch schon, wie der Hase läuft, also die SPD wird wieder
zu einem Ja und Am sagen und sich mit so ein paar,
Dingen zufriedengeben, aber am Ende keinen nennenswerten Widerstand betreiben
und die CDU wird halt irgendwie das machen, was die CDU immer macht.
Nämlich im Wesentlichen eigentlich erstmal gar nichts. Also mit anderen Worten,
es wird dann erstmal wieder ein bisschen Rollback gemacht und böse Gesetze werden
zurückgenommen, die so ein bisschen Zukunft versprochen haben.
Was allerdings so die Verteidigungspolitik betrifft, denke ich mal,
ist die CDU sicherlich etwas,
wie soll ich das formulieren, nicht ganz so zurückhaltend, wie es jetzt mit
Scholz und der SPD gewesen ist.
Mit anderen Worten, wir können davon ausgehen, dass der Rüstungsetat steigen wird.
Ich glaube, es gibt auch schon die Ansage von 200 bis 300 Milliarden.
Weiterer Investitionen in den Rüstungssektor. Ich weiß nicht,
ob das war so dahergesagt.
Das ist jetzt kein konkreter Plan, aber es ist schon mal ausgerufen worden.
Es ist sicherlich auch schon davon auszugehen, auch das klang schon durch,
dass jetzt irgendwie diese Schuldenbremse natürlich aufgehoben wird,
weil es totaler Irrsinn ist, die noch beizubehalten.
Natürlich hat die CDU im Wahlkampf immer noch behauptet,
es wäre alles ganz wichtig weil es hat ja auch super funktioniert um die Ampelregierung
davon abzuhalten, irgendwie erfolgreich zu regieren und jetzt wo sie abgewählt
sind, ist es natürlich alles egal,
also macht dann irgendwie die CDU genau das gleiche und wird die Schuldenbremse
dann aussetzen, weil ansonsten hat sie einfach überhaupt gar keine Möglichkeit das zu finanzieren,
ja, ich weiß nicht, was hältst du denn von der Wahl?
Ja, also es ist jetzt nicht das schlechtest denkbare Ergebnis dabei rausgekommen,
aber ich hätte mir einfach lieber schwarz-grün gewünscht.
Und das ist leider durch das Wahlergebnis nicht möglich.
Ansonsten, was Scholz jetzt so von sich gegeben hat in der Situation fand ich in Ordnung.
Also er hat sich halt ganz klar auch gegen den Unsinn positioniert.
Welchen Unsinn?
Den Trump gerade veranstaltet.
Achso, ja gut, das ist ja einfach.
Ja,
naja, gut, Macron hatte da auch noch eine etwas andere Position,
aber seine Ansage oder Analyse war auf den Punkt gebracht, Das sieht so aus,
dass die USA sich für Europa in Zukunft nicht mehr interessieren.
Das heißt, wir müssen irgendwie unseren eigenen Kram machen.
Das war in der Nutshell das Ding.
Für ihn als Transatlantiker war das jetzt nicht unbedingt zu erwarten,
dass er da so relativ klare Kante. Natürlich nicht unbedingt provokativ.
Trump hat dann der CDU zum Wahlsieg gratuliert, hat den Rechtsruck in Deutschland begrüßt.
Allerdings hat er mehr als gratuliert, ohne seinen Namen zu erwähnen.
Den kannte er wahrscheinlich noch nicht.
Ja, und natürlich ist ihm offenbar komplett entgangen,
dass eigentlich die AfD die Trumpisten sind und nicht an der Regierung beteiligt sein werden.
Oder zumindest, ja, war das auch etwas bizarr.
Dieser Tweet auf True Social, heißen alle Tweets einfach, egal wo sie, welcher Plattform.
Ja, ist ja auch richtig. Tweet ist halt, man weiß ja, was ein Tweet ist,
egal ob der bei Twitter oder woanders stattfindet.
Ja, okay, du hattest mich gefragt, was ich jetzt von der Regierung halte.
Ja, so schwarz-rot ist ganz schön ausgeleiert, irgendwie das Konzept,
was aber vielleicht damals auch ein bisschen was mit Merkel zu tun hatte und
anderen Protagonisten.
Aber es ist nicht gut so, weil tendenziell Regierungsparteien,
wenn sie regieren, Und Prozente verlieren meistens,
außer irgendwas Spezielles passiert.
Aber das Default ist, dass du dich eigentlich in der Regierung abnutzt und in
der Opposition regenerierst.
Aber das Problem ist, wenn man jetzt der AfD keine Gelegenheit gibt,
was man auch nicht kann, sich in der Regierung abzunutzen,
dann ist das natürlich langfristig einfach ein Problem.
So sehe ich das Ganze.
Aber aktuell ist, glaube ich, wichtig, dass es schnell eine handlungsfähige
Regierung gibt, die irgendwas entscheidet.
Und ja, bemerkenswert ist, dass es wohl jetzt bereits Gespräche gibt,
die Schuldenbremse noch vom aktuellen Parlament aussetzen zu lassen.
Bevor das neue Parlament sich konstituiert, weil dort haben eben SPD,
Grüne, CDU, CSU aktuell noch 70,8 Prozent.
Im neuen Parlament haben SPD, Grüne und CDU, CSU keine verfassungsändernde Mehrheit mehr.
Das heißt, falls es jetzt um Dinge geht, geht im Rahmen der Schuldenbremse,
wo es darum geht, dauerhafte Veränderungen vorzunehmen,
könnte theoretisch das aktuelle Parlament das noch mit diesen drei Fraktionen tun.
Aber die Zeit dafür wäre wahrscheinlich knapp.
Die letzte Sitzung ist ja auch schon durch. Also das Parlament wird erst wieder
in der neuen Konstellation zusammenkommen. Es gibt keine Abstimmung mehr.
Also ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob sowas nicht zur Not noch einberufen werden
kann, aber jetzt rein formal ist jetzt die letzte Sitzungswoche beendet.
Aber das kann natürlich schon sein, solange das Neue noch nicht da,
aber da habe ich jetzt keine Ahnung von dem Prozess.
Aber das stimmt, also wir haben jetzt Linke und AfD, die sozusagen in der Lage
wären, eine Verfassungsänderung zu blockieren und das natürlich gerade im Punkto Rüstung ein Thema.
Wenn die auch auf vollkommen unterschiedlichen Motivationen daraus hier entscheiden
würden. Aber ich glaube, das ist wirklich ein Problem.
Ja, das heißt, was sie halt machen müssen, ist eben Notstand zu erklären,
um diese Fiskalregeln auszusetzen.
Ja, dann stellt sich natürlich noch die Frage, speziell in Deutschland,
auch nach Wiedereinführung der Wehrpflicht.
Wenn jetzt wir mehr Armee brauchen, das ist natürlich ein kontroverses Thema.
Nicht nur, dass das eine Belastung für die Bevölkerung darstellt,
nämlich für junge Leute,
die ein bis zwei Jahre das mitmachen müssen.
Die Frage ist auch, wie effizient ist das eigentlich und ist eine Wehrpflichtarmee
denn jetzt das, was man heutzutage braucht?
So, weil wir haben wurde ja aus Gründen auch ausgesetzt.
Es bräuchte dazu jetzt keine Verfassungsänderung. Das kann mit einer einfachen
Mehrheit einfach beschlossen werden, weil die steht ja noch.
Die Wehrpflicht gibt es ja noch, sie wird nur nicht umgesetzt, nur nicht angewendet.
Aber es fehlen natürlich auch viele Supportstrukturen und Waffen und alles.
Also es wäre ein Riesenproblem.
Aber vermutlich der einzige Weg, um genügend Soldaten rekrutieren zu können.
Weil der Wehrdienst war nämlich eines der Hauptrekrutierungstools,
wenn man so will, der Bundeswehr.
Weil Leute, die dann da waren, haben gesehen, okay, das liegt mir irgendwie.
Ist, kann ich mir vorstellen.
Das möchte ich jetzt weitermachen oder das möchte ich gerne beruflich machen.
Und das wäre halt, das ist halt die eine Sache.
Die andere Sache ist, dass du, das hat sich jetzt auch gezeigt in dem Konflikt,
du brauchst halt heutzutage noch Masse.
Also du brauchst auch Soldatenmassen. So im Krieg, für alle möglichen Dinge.
Und du kannst dir das aber nicht leisten. Du kannst jetzt, also Deutschland
kann sich jetzt keine stehende Armee mit eine Million Soldaten leisten,
die vielleicht nötig wäre.
Sondern, und dafür ist die Wehrpflicht halt eben auch eine Lösung.
Das heißt, du hast halt einen professionellen Kern Und dann hast du eben eine Reserve,
die dann dafür sorgt, dass im Falle der Fälle du genug Leute hast und die schnell
ins Gefecht werfen kannst und die dann eben auch für eine glaubwürdige Abschreckung
sorgen, so wie Finnland.
Ob man das jetzt tun sollte oder nicht, ich meine langfristig.
Das wäre jetzt die andere Sache. Kann man sich natürlich vorstellen,
dass du eine kleine Armee hast,
die mit Robotern und Drohnen schwärmen und statt 100 Kampffiloten für 100 Kampfflugzeuge,
hast du dann 50 Kampffiloten, die dann aber 1000 Flugzeuge fliegen,
so mit einem Bemannten und zehn Unbemannten um sie herum oder so.
Also, aber da sind wir noch nicht.
Digitalisierung, ja, in Deutschland.
Das macht eine Witze.
Also, naja, aber dahin wird es wahrscheinlich in 10,
20 oder 30 Jahren irgendwie sich entwickeln oder hat sich ein bisschen in die
Richtung ja auch entwickelt.
Aber wenn man jetzt Lehren aus dem Ukraine-Krieg ziehen möchte,
dann kann man sagen, im Moment sind Bodentruppen unverzichtbar.
Und konventionelle Waffen, Artillerie, Kampfflugzeuge, all der ganze Kram.
Aber natürlich eben auch Drohnen, elektronische Kampfführung,
all der ganze Kladderadatsch.
Und vor allem ja auch nicht nur Kampf, sondern auch Logistik.
Also im Wesentlichen ist Militär Logistik und dafür brauchst du halt einfach
auch eine entsprechende Personalmasse.
Übrigens aktuelle Zahlen, zumindest auf dem Papier, aktive Soldaten,
Bundeswehr 181.000 und eine Reserve, eine theoretische Reserve von 930.000.
Also auf dem Wikipedia-Papier, ne?
Ja, ja, ich weiß. Die werden natürlich nicht alle wirklich im Zugriff sein,
aber das ist zumindest das, was so derzeit die Statistik besagt.
Ja, aber früher hatten wir halt auch, hatten diese Truppen, diese Reservisten,
alle auch schwere Waffen und LKW und den ganzen Kram.
Und das wurde halt, soweit ich weiß, zum großen Teil abgeschafft.
Das heißt, die Leute sind vielleicht da, aber die Waffen sind nicht da für die Leute.
Keine Frage, ich wollte nur mal ein paar Zahlen in den Raum schmeißen,
von wie vielen Leuten wir denn jetzt eigentlich reden, die derzeit von dem aktuellen
System, wie wir es jetzt haben,
im Nachgang einer Wehrpflicht, die seit 14 Jahren ausgesetzt ist,
jetzt sozusagen noch offiziell zur Bundeswehr zählen.
Dienstleistungsreserve sozusagen wird halt dann auch immer weniger und aktive
Soldaten weiß nicht ganz genau, wie sich das derzeit verhält. Naja.
Ja, aber insgesamt hat Europa oder der Teil, also der nicht amerikanische Teil
der NATO hat deutlich mehr aktive Soldaten als die USA.
Ja, das kann man vielleicht auch bemerken. Das heißt,
sind jetzt zwar für sich genommen jetzt oder relativ gesehen vielleicht an der
Bevölkerung nicht ganz so viele wie in der USA, aber es nimmt sich nicht viel.
Problem ist, dass die USA halt bei einigen Waffensystemen und einigen Fähigkeiten essentiell sind.
Sowas wie Tanker und Transportflugzeuge und Logistik und bei bestimmten Raketensystemen und so, Flugabwehr,
so geht es halt ohne die USA erstmal im Moment nicht.
Und Space Force.
Ja, und,
Ja,
also die Debatte, ob die Wehrpflicht wieder eingeführt werden soll,
wird uns sicherlich jetzt in den nächsten Monaten begleiten.
Noch ist sie nicht prominent aufgeflammt, aber schwierige Entscheidung.
Aber vermutlich der einzige Weg, wenn man eine glaubwürdig große Armee haben
möchte, so wie die Finnen das machen. Im Prinzip.
Und die Finnen haben das deswegen gemacht, weil sie eben nicht in der NATO waren
und nicht auf den Schutz der NATO hoffen konnten.
Und wir werden uns jetzt eben dementsprechend auch so verhalten müssen,
wenn wir uns jetzt nicht auf den Schutz der USA verlassen können,
dass wir dann eben für ausreichend Abschreckung sorgen,
damit die Russen einfach erstmal gar nichts versuchen.
Und das Problem natürlich ist so, wenn es jetzt zu einem Waffenstillstand in der Ukraine kommt,
wir können nicht erwarten, dass Russland jetzt dann gleich seine Truppen dem
Befehl geben wird, ins Baltikum zu marschieren.
Also da müssen sie auch erstmal regenerieren.
Aber so wenn Russland weiter Aufrüstungskurs fährt, was wir nicht wissen,
könnten sie in ein paar Jahren einfach an dem Punkt sein.
Zumal wenn die Ukraine nicht mehr das Problem ist, die jetzt im Moment,
ich weiß nicht, 700.000, 800.000 ihrer Truppen bindet, Und könnten Sie sich überlegen,
dann diesmal mit einer Million Truppen im Baltikum aufzumarschieren.
Gut, lass uns mal vorankommen und jetzt müssen wir auch ein bisschen über die
Ukraine selbst sprechen.
Das sind jetzt sozusagen erstmal so die Schockwellen der Neuausrichtung der
USA, von denen wir jetzt alle noch nicht genau wissen, wie sich in den nächsten
Wochen, Monaten und in den nächsten Jahren wirklich real ändern wird.
In gewisser Hinsicht ist ein Backlash
zu erwarten jetzt bei den aktuellen Aktionen, aber das weiß man nicht.
Und wie du schon richtig gesagt hast, Vertrauen ist zerstört.
Ich denke, niemand sagt jetzt gerade so, ja, ach der Trump, weißt du,
der regt sich auch schon wieder ab.
Dafür ist es einfach alles zu krass, zu massiv, zu direkt, zu gnadenlos,
zu erratisch auch und das spürt natürlich auch die Ukraine,
die ja lange Zeit darauf gesetzt hat oder sagen wir mal nach der Wahl darauf gesetzt hat,
einfach guter Partner der USA weiterhin zu sein, hat sich auch, sagen wir mal,
in den ganzen öffentlichen Bekundungen auch irgendwie klar so positioniert und
gesagt, das passt schon alles irgendwie und wir werden auch weiterhin da mitspielen,
was sollten sie halt auch anderes machen.
Was jetzt allerdings passiert ist, denke ich mal, übersteigt schon so ein bisschen
die Erwartungen, auch unsere Erwartungen.
Ich denke, unsere Erwartungen, die wir in der letzten Sendung geäußert haben,
lassen sich im Wesentlichen so zusammenfassen, dass man sagt.
Ja, er wird zwar alles irgendwie tun, um sozusagen seine eigene Taschen und
die seiner Cronies irgendwie zu füllen, ja.
Aber das ist ja eigentlich sehr viel einfacher wenn er einfach die Ukraine unterstützt,
aber nun macht es in zunehmendem Maße den Eindruck als ob er von dieser.
Wie soll ich das nennen dieser Verlockung,
der große Zampano in so einem mafiösen Kreis zu sein in dem sich irgendwie Saudi-Arabien
Russland, China ist bei ihm so ein bisschen schwierig also ne.
China wahrscheinlich nicht, aber eben Russland etc. drin tummeln,
ihre ganzen fossilen Freunde irgendwie das Geld geben, da fühlt er sich irgendwie wohl.
Und jetzt beginnt halt dieser Tanz und diese Verhandlungen, die da geführt werden
in Saudi-Arabien, sind halt keine Verhandlungen über den Frieden,
auch wenn sie offiziell so genannt werden,
sondern es sind halt Verhandlungen über, wer gibt mir das meiste Geld und von
wem kann ich am meisten profitieren und jetzt startet mal den gegenseitigen
Überbietungswettbewerb und ich bin bereit,
im Stundentakt oder auch im Tages- oder Wochentakt mein Fähnchen in einen anderen
Wind zu hängen und ich mache irgendwie alle verrückt.
Wir haben schon diesen Rohstoff-Deal angesprochen, wo halt irgendwie Trump jetzt
irgendwie versucht, ein Abkommen mit der Ukraine zu halten.
Auch dem Motto, ja, wenn wir euch nicht komplett fallen lassen,
dann müssen wir hier aber mal ordentlich eure Ressourcen abziehen.
So, nö, aber Sicherheitsgarantien wollen wir irgendwie auch nicht geben.
Und Truppen werden wir sowieso nicht schicken.
Das können ja mal die Europäer machen, wie du schon gesagt hast.
Und wenn die dann angegriffen werden, ist ja auch nicht unser Problem.
Das ist sozusagen jetzt diese ganze Kaskade, die zusammenkommt.
Das Verhalten den Russen gegenüber, auch seine Äußerungen den Russen gegenüber,
sein Abstimmungsverhalten in der UNO.
Es gab jetzt eine Resolution, die dann irgendwie diesen Krieg auf einmal als
Konflikt bezeichnet hat.
So macht das übrigens auch China, habe ich hier erfahren.
Ja, da ist nicht von Krieg die Rede, sondern von Konflikt. Also da hat man quasi
den Russen wieder was geschenkt.
Und das Ding ist, ich meine, Trump sieht sich natürlich so als super Dealmaker,
aber ich glaube, eigentlich ist er ja der totale Loser.
Auch seine ganzen Unternehmen sind ja eigentlich reihenweise pleite gegangen.
Es ist ein bisschen so ein Rätsel, wie er sich dann doch immer wieder am Leben erhalten hat.
Aber so richtig groß rausgekommen ist er eigentlich nie mit irgendetwas.
Sein Weg überhaupt, deswegen er wahrscheinlich wirtschaftlich überhaupt überlebt
hat Und wo er halt genug Geld mitgemacht hat,
war seine Fernsehrolle da in dieser amerikanischen Höhle des Löwen.
Mit You're Fired, die ihn, die sein Image aufgebaut haben,
die dann auch virtuelle Trump-Büros quasi in ein Studio aufgebaut hatten,
weil Trumps echtes Büro einfach so scheppig aussah,
dass sich das nicht fürs Fernsehen geeignet hätte.
Also deswegen haben sie halt so eine Scheinwelt, so ein Palast aufgebaut.
Die Trump-Führungszentrale war quasi eine Fernsehkulisse, wenn du so willst.
Und die echte Zentrale war halt irgendwo ein Loch.
The Apprentice heißt die.
Ja, The Apprentice, genau der.
Und damit hat er halt hunderte von Millionen gemacht.
Also das ist sozusagen der Hauptgrundstock seines Vermögens.
Und auch am Ende hat er damit auch seine Bekanntheit und das politische Kapital
darüber und das Image, sagen wir mal, darauf aufgebaut.
Also lustigerweise ähnlich wie Selensky, der quasi auch durch eine Fernsehrolle,
aber völlig anderer Art...
Auch nicht ansatzweise so gut bezahlt.
Ja, nicht so gut bezahlt, aber dadurch eben auch die Bekanntheit. Und ja, so.
Also beide haben eigentlich ihre Rolle im Unterhaltungsfernsehen zu verdanken, ihre Präsidentin.
Allerdings wurde Selenskyj von einer deutlichen Mehrheit gewählt.
Ja, hatte 70 Prozent und hat auch in einer ganz anderen Rolle,
nämlich als Korruptionsbekämpfer dort agiert.
Kommen wir nochmal so ein bisschen auf die Ukraine. Ehrlich gesagt, ich kann kein,
gerade kein wirklich schlüssiges Bild schildern oder habe selber kein schlüssiges Bild davon, wie...
Die Überlegungen aussehen, die derzeit in der Ukraine ablaufen.
Die Bevölkerung, bin ich überraschend, ist natürlich total schockiert von dem Verhalten der USA.
Das wird also als ein großer Verrat angesehen.
Also die Art und Weise allein, wie er Putin hofiert, die Tatsache,
dass er ihn überhaupt trifft.
Und jetzt auch noch, um dem Ganzen so die Krone aufzusetzen,
dieser Versuch irgendwie die Ukraine am Verhandlungstisch über denselben zu
ziehen und dann eben auch noch jetzt die bekannt gewordenen Deals,
die Trump versucht eben da mit Putin zu machen,
die übrigens auch die Russen aufregen.
Also gerade die Soldaten, die kotzen das jetzt auch total an,
dass jetzt auf einmal Putin, Trump irgendwelche Angebote macht.
Ja, wir sterben jetzt hier irgendwie für unser Land, damit irgendwie dann die
Rohstoffe im Donbass irgendwie den Amerikanern verkauft werden können,
die uns hier gerade irgendwie die Köppe einschießen mit ihren Raketen.
Das verstehen die halt irgendwie auch nicht. Also ich würde auch sagen,
das ganze Gebilde von Trump und Putin steht auch alles aus der Tönernen Füßen.
Trotz alledem haben wir eben das Problem, dass derzeit nach wie vor dieser Druck
der Russen eben sehr groß ist, weil Putin einfach weiterhin undenkbare Menschenmassen auffährt,
um die über die Felder laufen zu lassen, obwohl die Verluste derzeit extrem
hoch sind, die Fortschritte relativ gering sind, auch wenn es welche gibt.
In dieser Situation muss die Ukraine halt eine neue Strategie finden und muss
sich irgendwie orientieren und meine Einschätzung ist eher die,
dass die Ukraine sowohl natürlich ihrer Situation,
also ihrer Gesamtsituation sehr wohl bewusst ist, wo sie ihre Schwächen haben,
Aber ich glaube auch, dass die Ukraine sich mitnichten als hilflos ansieht.
Dass sie nicht sagen, oh mein Gott, wir sind verloren, wir müssen jetzt irgendwie
auf jeden Zug aufspringen und jeden Streit ergreifen, der uns gereicht wird, egal mit wie vielen,
Bedingungen er verknüpft ist.
Sondern die Ukraine hat auch was im.
Man kann auch was verlieren im Verhandeln mit der Ukraine und nicht nur irgendwelche Ressourcen.
Denn letztlich ist es so, dass die Ukraine und das ist, ich merke das auch an
den Kommentaren bei uns im Blog,
das ist ein sehr umstrittener Punkt, aber ich glaube das schon,
dass die Ukraine wird stärker, ist eine Frage der Zeit.
Und Russland wird schwächer, ist eine Frage der Zeit. Natürlich kann das auch
wieder ein Rückschlag erfahren, sollte zum Beispiel Trump jetzt die ganzen Sanktionen
gegen Russland zurücknehmen, das wäre natürlich hart.
Bleiben zwar immer noch die Sanktionen der EU, aber die Sanktionen der Amerikaner
sind derzeit sehr wichtig, insbesondere die sich jetzt auf die Schifffahrtsflotten
beziehen, aber eben auch nicht nur darauf.
Sollte also das wegfallen, schwächt es natürlich die Position der Ukraine.
Trotz alledem, die Ukraine wird stärker. Die Ukraine wird jetzt stärker werden,
dadurch, dass das europäische Engagement hochgeht.
Die Ukraine wird dadurch stärker, dass sie einfach seit Beginn des Krieges konsequent
am Aufbau ihrer eigenen Rüstungsindustrie gearbeitet haben.
Sie sind in einigen Bereichen mittlerweile führend, also ich meine bei Drohnen
kann in Ukrainer glaube ich deshalb einfach überhaupt keiner was vormachen.
Sie haben angestrebt gehabt eine Produktion von diesen FPV Drones pro Jahr von
ungefähr einer Million Stück zu erreichen im letzten Jahr.
Was ist bei rausgekommen? Zwei Millionen.
Allein in Prokowsk haben die binnen eines Monats 200.000 von diesen Drohnen
zum Einsatz gebracht auf dem Schlachtfeld.
Also damit sowohl russisches Soldatenpersonal als auch mechanisierte Angriffe zurückgeschlagen.
Und auch wenn das alles nicht reicht, um sozusagen Tod und Zerstörung durch
Raketenangriffe, durch vorstoßende Frontlinien etc.
Zu verhindern, zeigt sich, dass sich das Machtverhältnis Ukraine zu Russland
verändert und zwar zugunsten der Ukraine.
Nicht in allen Bereichen, aber in manchen Bereichen, auch in manchen Bereichen,
wo es bisher so aussah, als könnte sich das nie ändern.
Zum Beispiel Artillerie, was immer noch eine der wichtigsten Waffengattungen
ist, die in diesem Krieg entscheidend sind oder mitentscheidend sind.
Wir hatten eine Übermacht der Russen von 10 zu 1 ungefähr, was die Verfügbarkeit
von Artilleriegerät und vor allem auch Munition betrifft.
Und darunter hat die ukrainische Verteidigungslinie immer sehr gelitten, ganz klar.
Mittlerweile ist dieser Vorteil,
laut Einschätzung, was ich so mitbekommen habe, nur noch so bei 2 zu 1.
Ja, habe ich auch gehört.
Ist noch ein Vorteil, aber ist definitiv eine ganz andere Ansage.
Gibt natürlich auch Waffengattungen, da machen es die Russen den Ukrainern nach wie vor sehr schwer.
Gleitbombs zum Beispiel, aber auch hier hat die Ukraine halt schon nachgeliefert
und ist jetzt auch selber in die Produktion von Gleitbombs gegangen.
Also sie holen da auf und durch diesen Trend, dass die europäischen Nationen
nicht selber Waffen liefern, sondern einfach sagen, hier nimmt das Geld, baut das selber auf,
dadurch verstärkt sich eben das Ganze noch.
In anderen Worten, die Ukraine hat was zu bieten. Die Ukraine ist jetzt sozusagen
nicht schwach im eigentlichen Sinne.
Sie sind halt im Krieg, ganz klar, aber es ist eben trotzdem ein starkes Land,
was in der Lage ist, seine eigene Widerstandsfähigkeit weiter zu unterfüttern.
Ja, meine eine Frage,
die ich mir jetzt gestellt habe, war eben auch in dem Zusammenhang,
wenn es jetzt zu einem Waffenstillstand käme, also es ist nicht zu erwarten,
dass es quasi im ersten Schritt einen Friedensvertrag geben wird,
der alles umfassend regelt, Sondern man wird sich auf irgendeinen Prozess vereinbaren
mit mehreren Schritten.
Zug um Zug wird dann dies oder jenes passieren.
Und es wird dann mit einem Waffenstillstand beginnen. erst mal.
Und da ist die Frage dann natürlich, wer würde im Moment mehr von einem Waffenstillstand profitieren?
Aktuell.
Die Russen.
Und ja,
Das ist halt, ich finde es ist nicht ganz so leicht zu beurteilen und entscheidend ist auch,
was sagen an der Stelle die Russen und die Ukrainer glauben,
wer von einem Waffenstillstand profitieren würde.
Und Fakt ist, dass die Russen derzeit die Initiative haben an verschiedenen
Fronten wieder, aber das eben nicht durchhalten können.
Dass man sehen kann, okay, die kommen so langsam, also ja, von der Intensität her. Ja, so.
Ukraine könnte natürlich auch ihre Befestigungen verbessern und beide Seiten
könnten Munition und Waffen aufstocken und Personal ausbilden. So, ja.
Und es ist schwierig zu sagen, wer von einem Waffenstillstand tatsächlich mehr profitieren würde.
Also ich fühle mich außerstande, das zuverlässig im Moment zu sagen.
Aber ich glaube, dass die Russen glauben oder zumindest behaupten,
dass die Ukraine profitieren würde und dass die Ukrainer bislang geglaubt haben
oder sich geäußert haben, dass Russland profitieren würde.
Also ich glaube vor allem, dass die Ukrainer nicht glauben, dass sich die Russen
sich an einen Waffenstillstand halten würden.
Also dieses Vertrauen in irgendein Abkommen oder auch nur irgendein Zwischenergebnis
mit Russland, das ist einfach nicht da.
Ja.
Also ich halte das für komplett hypothetisch, irgendwie Waffenstillstand zu vereinbaren.
Also wer soll das vereinbaren?
Mit welcher Kraft?
Mit welchem.
Naja, da würden beide Seiten sagen, okay, an dem und dem Tag um so und so viel
Uhr, so werden wir jetzt sagen.
Kein weiteres. Aber dazu müsste ja die Ukraine und Russland miteinander reden.
Das wird nicht passieren.
Naja, das wird nicht passieren.
Nein, das Ding ist, die Ukrainer glauben den Russen gar nichts.
Ja, ja, ja.
Ja, also werden sie auch nicht miteinander reden. Und wenn sie nicht miteinander
reden, dann wird da halt auch nichts kommen.
Also Trump wird sie irgendwann dazu holen,
wird ihnen wahrscheinlich irgendwas vorsetzen, was er mit Putin irgendwie ausgehandelt hat.
Und dann wird die Frage sein, wie sich die Ukraine dazu verhalten wird und wie
sich Europa dazu verhalten wird.
Also Europa, ja, also ich sehe das nicht kommen, ganz ehrlich,
ich sehe das nicht kommen, weil die Ukraine so nicht mit sich umgehen lassen wird.
Und schon gar nicht die Europäer außen vor lässt.
Also die Ukrainer werden nicht den Fehler machen, für Trump Europa vor die Tür
zu setzen, sondern für die Ukraine ist ab jetzt Europa der wichtigste Verbündete.
Zumal, wenn Europa die Bereitschaft klar signalisiert, zu sagen,
wir werden jetzt für die Aufrüstung sorgen, es ist unser Sicherheitsinteresse,
dass die Ukraine überlebt und wir denken jetzt auch schrittweise darüber nach,
härtere Maßnahmen zu ergreifen.
Es gab die Wortäußerung vom polnischen Ministerpräsidenten, man hat das gesehen,
er hat es ja gleich getwittert.
So, hier Schluss mit lustig, wir müssen jetzt irgendwie handeln und zwar jetzt
sofort und wir sollten jetzt mal die 300 Milliarden US-Dollar,
die die Russen noch an Assets in Europa haben, was eingefroren ist,
komplett einfach für die Rüstung der Ukraine ausgeben und fertig und die Russen
kriegen irgendwie gar nichts mehr wieder und so läuft jetzt der Rase.
Klar, das ist die polnische Meinung, die vertreten jetzt nicht alle,
aber die Debatten werden jetzt auf jeden Fall härter geführt werden.
Natürlich werden die von Russland abhängigen Länder, vor allem natürlich Ungarn,
aber schwierig auch noch ein paar andere nicht bei allem mitziehen,
aber ich glaube Ungarn ist derzeit irgendwie weitgehend unter Kontrolle,
weil die EU genug Druckmittel hat.
Die werden sich also sozusagen von Ungarn nicht austanzen lassen und ich kann
mir eben vorstellen, dass es noch weitere Länder gibt, wenn man jetzt mal so
durchgeht Baltikum ist eh klar Polen auch und ich denke auch Tschechien.
Ist sozusagen auf so einem Posten, wenn sie jetzt auch nicht klar sagen,
wir gehen jetzt hier mit Truppen rein, aber,
gibt die Bereitschaft, mehr zu tun, als derzeit getan wird. Oder?
Würdest du das für Tschechien auch noch so unterschreiben?
Deutschland, naja, da steht jetzt Merz in gewisser Hinsicht schon im Wort,
weil er eben vor der Wahl so rumgepoltert hat und mit uns gibt es jetzt hier
sofort Taurus und Pipapo.
Also das wäre ja dann irgendwie eine sehr schnelle Kehrtwende,
wenn er da jetzt irgendwie auf einmal auf die Bremse treten würde.
Macron war der überhaupt der allererste, der dieses Gespräch schon geführt hat
mit französischen Truppen in der Ukraine,
auch wenn es noch alles ein bisschen testbettmäßig war und ein bisschen unkonkret
und im Prinzip auch nochmal wiederholt werden müsste.
Und die Briten, naja, weiß ich nicht so ganz genau, ist noch ein bisschen unklar,
die sind aber definitiv sowieso einer der größten Unterstützer der Ukraine.
Dann hast du irgendwie Finnland im Wesentlichen auch mit im Boot ich glaube
die richtigen Bremser sind derzeit eigentlich eher so Italien oder Spanien und
so die aber vielleicht auch gar nicht so eine große Rolle spielen,
tendenziell formt sich da so langsam eine andere Meinung.
Ja mein Problem ist,
Natürlich, also wenn wir jetzt sagen über europäische Friedenstruppen in der Ukraine sprechen,
was ja Trump mehr oder weniger verlangt oder was die einzige im Moment verbleibende
Variante ist von Garantien,
Wobei am Ende die USA zumindest dann ihren Rückzug aus anderen Teilen Europas aussetzen müssten.
Was Trump ja generell auch in der letzten Amtszeit gemacht hat und auch dieses
Mal wieder zu erwarten ist, ist, dass er amerikanische Truppen aus Europa abzieht.
Unter beiden wurden ja 20.000 wieder zurückgeschickt nach Europa.
Also wurde aufgestockt, aber Trump wird wahrscheinlich oder plant,
halt auch generell von überall Truppen abzuziehen.
Er hat, glaube ich, schon angekündigt,
dass jetzt in Griechenland ein Militärstützpunkt geschlossen wird.
Ja, so. Und was natürlich ein bisschen eng wird, ist zu sagen,
wenn die USA einerseits Truppen von überall abzieht und dann eben Europa jetzt
dann auch noch in nennenswerter Anzahl Friedenstruppen in die Ukraine schicken soll.
Und da kommt es dann wiederum darauf an, die Truppen, die dann geschickt werden,
sind die mehr als ein sogenannter Tripwire.
Also sind sie dort, dass sie, wenn sie dann angegriffen werden,
das dann als Eskalation gewertet wird und dann dadurch ein Krieg mit Russland ausgelöst wird.
Oder sind es genug Truppen?
Um Russland tatsächlich davon abzuhalten, irgendwie die Grenze zu überqueren.
Und geht davon aus, wenn die Friedenstruppen tatsächlich die Russen jetzt abhalten sollten,
irgendwas zu versuchen,
dass man so größenordnungsmäßig 100.000 bis 200.000 Leute bräuchte,
Was halt im Moment einfach,
was zwar einerseits rechnerisch möglich wäre, aber wenn man dann davon ausgeht,
okay, was ist logistisch?
Also es würde einfach gerade derzeit einige Militärs komplett entblößen.
So und ja, also so viele freie Truppen, wie man eigentlich bräuchte,
um wirklich Sicherheit zu garantieren,
sind in Europa nicht bewegbar.
Man würde ja der Ukraine auch schon helfen, wenn man sagen würde,
das haben wir ja auch schon mal besprochen, wir gehen jetzt in Bereiche rein,
die nicht an der Frontlinie sind und wir unterstützen die Logistik.
Das ist für reine Aufstockung, zumindest schon mal im Kampf.
Friedenssicherung würde ja davon ausgehen, dass es irgendwie wirklich eine Einstellung
der Kämpfe gegeben hätte und dass man jetzt hier irgendwie eine Situation erreicht
hat, wo die Russen freiwillig aufhören würden zu kämpfen.
Und ich sage, wird nicht stattfinden. Die Russen geben nicht freiwillig auf.
Die werden nicht durch Verhandlungen mit Trump oder sonst irgendjemanden aufhören, diesen Krieg zu führen.
Die einzige Möglichkeit ist, dass sie diesen Krieg verlieren.
Ja, man wird sehen. Also im Moment jedenfalls sagen, es gibt ja,
also es ist ja nicht so, dass es keine Bemühungen gäbe.
Also alle wollen eigentlich, dass diese Kämpfe, dass dieser Krieg aufhört.
Du meinst einschließlich der Russen?
Ja, die Russen hätten gerne, dass der Krieg aufhört und die Ukraine sich in Ägypten ergibt.
Ja, klar.
Aber da weiß sich die Kasse im Schwarz.
Ja, und die Europäer und die Ukrainer hätten gerne, dass der Krieg zu Ende ist
und die Russen das Land verlassen.
Und irgendwo dazwischen, da besteht die Hoffnung, dass man sich irgendwie dazwischen einigen kann.
Und da gibt es natürlich auch diese diversen Strategiespielchen,
aber ja, also das Ganze, also wo ich dir recht gebe, ist,
dass ich nicht sehe, wie das Ganze zu einem dauerhaften, nachhaltigen Frieden
führen kann, was da gerade abläuft.
Aber ich halte es für durchaus möglich, dass es zu einem Waffenstillstand kommt.
Und wenn es so ist, wie du sagst, dass die Russen davon profitieren würden, würden sie das ja tun.
Und wenn sie dann glauben, dass die Ukrainer das dann nicht ausnutzen und sie
dann überrennen, warum nicht?
Also ob der dann halten wird und wie lange, ist dann auch nochmal eine andere
Sache. aber ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass es dazu kommt.
Ja, also insgesamt zu der Frage jetzt mit europäischen Friedenstruppen,
da ist so viel noch im Unklaren, so viel, was geklärt werden müsste.
Also zum Beispiel wird es mit Abrüstungseinkommen einhergehen,
also wird Russland zur Abrüstung verpflichtet, wird die Ukraine zur Abrüstung verpflichtet.
Gibt es irgendwie dann eine demilitarisierte Pufferzone irgendwo?
So, dann die Frage, was ist der Status russischer besetzter Gebiete?
Ich meine, will Trump versuchen, die Ukraine zu zwingen, sie dauerhaft abzugeben?
Da wird die Ukraine sicherlich nicht mitgehen.
So, aber sozusagen vorübergehend unter russischer Verwaltung könnte dann das
Ergebnis sein. Dann ist die Frage, welche Kontroll- und Sanktionsmechanismen wird es geben?
So kann es überhaupt effiziente Mechanismen geben?
Und dann wird natürlich die Frage der eingefrorenen Mittel natürlich auch eine
wichtige Rolle spielen an irgendeinem Punkt.
Also Putin liegt da sehr, sehr viel dran. Das weiß man, weil 300 Milliarden
sind eine dicke Stange Geld.
Und Trump wird sicherlich auch was davon abhaben wollen.
Und könnte versucht sein, den Russen das wieder zuzuschauen.
Es ist jedenfalls so viel einfach noch offen.
Dass es vollkommen unklar ist. Aber mein ein Punkt,
der mir auch nicht so klar war bis heute,
ist die Dimensionen der russischen Verluste im Vergleich zum Zweiten Weltkrieg jetzt.
Nämlich, dass die Russen jetzt mehr Leute verloren haben als die USA im Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Und das ist, glaube ich, ein Faktor, der jetzt auch da an irgendeinem Punkt
einfach reinspielen wird und reinspielen muss,
dass diese Verluste, diese immensen,
da wird Russland natürlich auch was für haben wollen, damit sich der Deal lohnt.
Also wenn Putin jetzt nach Hause kommt und gefragt wird, was hast du denn jetzt
gekriegt für das alles so und das alles könnte halt einen Deal, also das.
Es gibt mehr Möglichkeiten, dass dieser Deal platzt als alles andere.
Insofern sehe ich auch deine Skepsis im Moment.
Ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen, dass mehr als ein paar Monate Waffenstillstand
dabei rauskommen, wenn überhaupt.
Ja und ich kann mir noch nicht mal das vorstellen zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt.
Also ich denke nicht, dass wir irgendeine nennenswerte Entwicklung haben werden,
weil so wie Trump sich verhält, gibt es überhaupt gar kein Vertrauen in was
auch immer er irgendwie unterschrieben bekommt.
Es gibt weder das Vertrauen in Putin, noch gibt es das Vertrauen in Trump.
Und damit ist er eigentlich für die Ukraine, die USA weitgehend gestorben.
Und wir werden jetzt eine echte europäische Allianz benötigen.
Und wahrscheinlich werden wir auch eine europäische Allianz erhalten.
Ob das Attribut echt sich dann verdient, das werden wir noch mal sehen.
Da bin ich noch ein bisschen skeptisch.
Da wird jetzt auch viel von Deutschland abhängen. Nicht nur,
aber auch, wenn Deutschland jetzt mal zu einem aktiven Player werden könnte in diesem Spiel.
Also nicht, dass jetzt Deutschlands Beitrag zur Verteidigung der Ukraine bisher nichts gewesen wäre.
Klar, so in reinen Zahlen, Gerät, Material, Waffen und so weiter waren wir schon dabei,
aber Deutschland war halt auch die ganze Zeit ganz weit vorne die Spaßbremse,
wenn es darum ging, halt irgendwie mal klare Entscheidungen zu fällen und das
ist halt so ein bisschen das Problem.
Natürlich eben auch eingeschränkt durch das Wirken der Opposition,
aber die kann man da einfach auch nur beschränkt für verantwortlich machen.
Und das wäre jetzt einfach erforderlich. Aber ich glaube nicht,
dass die Ukraine sich auf irgendeinen Fadendeal einlässt, jetzt wo sie merken,
dass sie eigentlich, ja...
Mit der Zeit eigentlich immer besser dastehen. Wie gesagt, da gibt es sehr unterschiedliche
Auffassungen darüber, ob die Zeit jetzt für Russland arbeitet oder für die Ukraine.
Ich sehe es nach wie vor so, dass es eben tendenziell für die Ukraine arbeitet,
auch wenn wir jetzt gerade in der Phase im Krieg sind.
Wir haben jetzt über militärische Updates nicht so viel gesprochen oder gar
nicht gesprochen in dieser Ausgabe.
Im Prinzip gilt noch das, was wir letztes Mal gesagt haben, dass die Russen
halt überall drücken und so weiter. Aber einfach gerade mit horrenden Verlusten
agieren und auch irgendwann an ihre Grenzen kommen werden.
Und zwar an ihre aktuellen Grenzen. Es sind gerade auch nochmal so Statistiken
veröffentlicht worden von der Ukraine, was so die Verluste der Russen im ersten,
zweiten und dritten Jahr war.
Weil wir haben jetzt, haben wir noch gar nicht erwähnt,
ich meine wir sind jetzt hier irgendwie gerade vier Tage nach dem Jahrestag
des Beginns dieses Krieges,
dieser Aufnahme und im letzten Jahr haben die Russen im Prinzip nochmal genauso
viel Verluste gehabt wie in den ersten beiden Jahren zusammen.
Also es nimmt vielleicht nicht exponentiell aber es nimmt deutlich zu.
Und das ist halt auch einfach irgendwann nicht mehr handelbar klar,
sie können lange durchhalten, Putin hat einen langen Atem, weil er eben auch
derzeit überhaupt gar kein Interesse daran hat, diesen Krieg zu beenden weil
würde er in diesem aktuellen Zustand beenden, wäre das Ergebnis halt vernichtend schlecht.
Deswegen wird der weiterlaufen.
Egal was diese Deals mit Trump sagen. Ehrlich gesagt, ich bin gar nicht bereit,
diesen Verhandlungen viel Aufmerksamkeit zu schenken.
Ich denke, da werden einfach nur weitere Betrugsversuche bei rauskommen und
sonst eigentlich herzlich wenig. und ich hoffe, dass die Ukrainer ihm halt nicht
auf den Leim gehen, kann es mir aber auch ehrlich gesagt irgendwie nicht so richtig vorstellen.
Wichtig ist, dass Europa jetzt sein Eck zusammenbekommt und dann eine wirklich
schlagkräftige Allianz,
bildet und entsprechend finanziert und vor allem auch handelt und dann im Idealfall
eben auch geeint, wirklich geeint handelt und daraus seine Konsequenzen zieht
im Kontext all dem, was wir jetzt hier vorher schon gesagt haben.
Aspekt ist jetzt noch von dem ganzen Chaos,
das Trump produziert, dass ich auch das Gefühl habe, dass er auch die Russen
mit ins Chaos stürzen könnte.
Ich weiß nicht, wie weit du die russischen Reaktionen verfolgt hast,
von dem riesigen Jubel, der da natürlich war und Begeisterung für Trump und
sie konnten es irgendwie kaum fassen.
Aber er hat halt jetzt in Russland auch Erwartungen geweckt.
Und die Eliten freuen sich schon wieder, dass sie endlich ihre Jachten wieder investen dürfen.
Und wenn das jetzt alles den Bach runtergeht, dann könnte das auch sein,
dass das Russland destabilisiert.
Dass Trump im Moment,
ja, die Russen sind eigentlich ja diejenigen, die unglaublich viel Unsinn und
hanebüchenden Unsinn verzapfen.
Aber ich glaube, das Level, was Trump da einfach gerade fabriziert,
der ihnen jetzt gerade irgendwie ihre eigene Medizin zum Trinken gibt und insbesondere,
ja,
also ich glaube nicht, dass das, was Trump tut, unbedingt...
Positiv von der russischen Bevölkerung aufgenommen wird oder aufgenommen werden
wird, wenn das am Ende nicht irgendwie gut läuft.
Und die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es gut läuft, für irgendjemanden ist extrem
gering, auch für Russland.
Deswegen sage ich ja, Putin hat derzeit kein Interesse daran,
den Krieg zu beenden, weil er unter diesen Bedingungen nicht beenden kann.
Leider ist Macht, ist seine Macht gefährdet.
Ja.
Und seine Macht soll nicht gefährdet werden, deswegen muss es weitergehen.
Das ist leider die bittere Logik.
Er ist jetzt bereit, weil er im Prinzip sieht, drei Jahre Krieg statt drei Tage Krieg.
Russlands Wirtschaft ist stark unter Druck. Wir haben hier gesprochen über diese
Stugflation, den Zustand der russischen Wirtschaft, zunehmende Sanktionen.
Das zieht sich wie eine Schlinge um den Hals des gesamten Landes,
auch wenn sie derzeit noch in der Lage sind, das irgendwie wegzulächeln,
weil sie irgendwie in Moskau und St.
Petersburg so eine Illusion von Normalität aufrechterhalten,
indem sie alle Ressourcen dort konzentriert verteilen.
Aber der rest des landes hat halt irgendwie darunter zu leiden und ewig geht
es halt so nicht weiter auch wenn es immer noch.
Weiter geht, als uns das allen lieb sein kann, weil halt einfach gnadenlos alles verheizt wird.
Aber irgendwann ist halt auch der letzte Reservepanzer aus dem Lager geholt
und irgendwann geht es einfach nicht mehr weiter und finanziell ist das jetzt
schon alles nicht mehr zu stemmen.
Dazu kommt, wenn jetzt irgendwie die Wirtschaft, die sich jetzt komplett auf
Militärproduktion umgestellt hat, morgen irgendwie in so einen Friedensmodus
übergeht, dann ist sowieso erstmal wirtschaftlicher Niedergang angesagt.
Das ist eine natürliche Folge, das gab es sogar in den USA nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg, weil man halt einfach erstmal wieder auf normale Produktionen umstellen muss.
Und dafür hat einfach Russland auch derzeit überhaupt nicht die Ressourcen.
Wir haben über Brain Drain gesprochen, wir haben durch die hohen Verluste natürlich
auch einfach Verluste in der Workforce gesprochen, die Schulden,
die hier aufgetürmt wurden.
Also so vieles führt dazu, dass Putin eigentlich gar keine andere Wahl hat,
als diesen Krieg fortzusetzen, bis er irgendwann so einen unfassbaren Sieg davon
zieht, dass ihm auch alles verziehen wird und das kann halt derzeit auch nicht passieren.
Von daher sind die Russen total in der Zwickmühle und das Einzige,
was ihnen jetzt noch helfen kann, ist halt irgendwie eine Selbstauflösung der USA.
Und da ist halt Trump gerade wunderbar dabei, aus ganz anderen Motivationen
heraus und das ist für die halt irgendwie eigentlich so ein Glücksmoment,
aber auf der anderen Seite wissen sie halt sich auch nicht so richtig drüber
zu freuen, zumal eben jetzt so ein positives,
ja wir sind jetzt wieder alle Freunde und wir treffen uns hier irgendwie in
Saudi-Arabien und finden es ja eigentlich ganz knorkel und wollt ja nicht irgendwie
ein bisschen Aluminium kaufen.
Kommt dann halt wiederum bei den Soldaten und bei der Bevölkerung halt dann
irgendwie auch nicht an, die jetzt irgendwie jahrelang erzählt bekommen hat,
dass halt irgendwie die USA der Antichrist sind und ja, der größte Feind Russlands.
Also es passt einfach vorne und hinten alles nicht zusammen.
Die einzigen, die irgendwie eine klare Erzählung haben, ist die Ukraine und
das wird ihnen irgendwann auch nochmal positiv,
ausgelegt werden. oder wird für sie positive Folgen haben.
Lass uns mal zum Ende kommen. Haben wir noch ein paar Dinge,
die wir noch behandeln wollen?
Vielleicht ein paar kleinere Fragen nochmal abarbeiten. Was meinst du?
Ja, also ich denke, so eine Frage,
das meiste haben wir schon beantwortet, aber eine Frage, denke ich,
ist, ob die Ukraine mit europäischer Unterstützung alleine weiterkämpfen kann.
Kann man, glaube ich, sagen grundsätzlich ja.
So hängt natürlich von der europäischen Unterstützung ab,
aber mit europäischer Europa hat die Wirtschaftskraft und die Technologie und
derzeit vermutlich auch den Willen, die Ukraine zu unterstützen.
Und Zelensky hat ja auch gesagt, die Ukraine hat am ersten Tag der Invasion
nicht aufgegeben, wo die Situation viel verzweifelter aussah.
Und dann werden sie nicht in dieser Situation jetzt die Waffen streichen,
in der sie sich jetzt befinden. Also das ist, sagen kann man das festhalten.
Dann an die Frage, ob sich denn, wenn sich die USA zurückziehen,
ob sich Europa gegen Russland ohne die USA verteidigen kann,
kann man glaube ich auch sagen,
kann man aber glaube ich auch ja sagen.
Zumindest im aktuellen Zustand der russischen Armee.
Ja, im aktuellen Zustand der russischen Armee und mit der Ukraine auf unserer Seite.
Das auch.
Da könnte man sich jetzt aber auch vorstellen, wenn jetzt die Ukraine russisch
wäre, dann hätten wir auch die Ukraine gegen uns.
Das will man nicht.
Und da könnte Putin dann versucht sein, aus irgendwelchen Gründen,
wie er das gerne macht, dann die Ukrainer gegen Westeuropa erstmal in den Krieg zu schicken.
Halte ich für alles. Aber nur wenn man jetzt dem Kapitulationsgedanken folgt
und sagt, die Ukrainer sollen sich doch lieber den Russen unterordnen,
die sind russisches Einflussgebiet, würde man sich klar machen, was das bedeuten würde.
Man kann auch davon ausgehen noch dazu,
sollte man jetzt ein bisschen extrem jetzt die Formulierung aber halt leider
nicht komplett unmöglich, aber würde jetzt Europa alleine ohne irgendeine,
Unterstützung der USA gegen Russland kämpfen,
womit ja dann die Europäer dann automatisch auch quasi die amerikanischen Waffen
also Militärstützpunkte Stützpunkte verteidigen müssten, weil es dann die Amerikaner
selber nicht mehr machen oder wie.
Also so ganz kann ich mir das nicht vorstellen.
Aber wäre es jetzt so, dann ist es ja auch nicht so, dass Europa nicht auch
noch weitere Verbündete bekommen würde.
Also Länder wie Japan, Korea, Südkorea, wären dann auf jeden Fall glaube ich
auf einer ganz anderen Motivationsebene auf einmal Unterstützung zu liefern.
Insbesondere Südkorea und weitere Verbündete.
Ja, und Europa hat Geld.
Ich meine, die nächste Frage, die sich natürlich aufdrängt, ist,
wie weit der Konflikt jetzt zwischen Europa und den USA eigentlich eskalieren
wird, weil es gibt jetzt auf jeden Fall definitiv einen Wertekonflikt.
Und und Konflikt um die Frage internationalem Recht und so weiter.
Und ich hoffe ja nicht sehr weit.
Ich hoffe, dass Trump eingehegt werden wird.
Aber da besteht natürlich auch gewisses Eskalationspotenzial.
In Europa versucht man derzeit natürlich überall zu deeskalieren.
Und Trump und Macron haben sich auch irgendwie so ein bisschen wie beste Buddies aufgeführt.
Also insofern alles so ein bisschen unklar. Wie siehst du das?
Naja, Macron hat ihn ja vor laufenden Kameras irgendwie korrigiert.
Ich glaube, dafür wird er sich rächen.
Ja.
Also Macron macht zwar immer so auf Buddy, weil er halt so ein Typ ist.
Weil er irgendwie eine gewisse Eleganz und Coolness am Start hat und keine Angst
zeigt. Das finde ich auch ganz geil an ihm.
Aber ich glaube, Trump wird sich bitterböse bei Frankreich. Also Frankreich ist wahrscheinlich,
Und sofern sie in der Lage sind, überhaupt Frankreich gegenüber irgendeinen Druck auszuüben,
wahrscheinlich wird, naja der Käse ist ja eh schon verboten,
also ihm wird schon irgendwas einfallen,
vielleicht werden sie es rein technisch wieder nicht richtig auf die Kette kriegen,
wie beim letzten Mal ja auch, wo sie schon versucht haben gegen einzelne Länder
vorzugehen, ein bisschen gecheckt haben, dass das irgendwie eine Europäische
Union ist, die gemeinsame,
Handelsbeziehung pflegt etc.
Und dass dann automatisch gleich für alle gilt, aber ich glaube,
der Konflikt zwischen Europa und den USA wird weiter eskalieren.
Da gibt es, glaube ich, sehr viele Bereiche, allerdings muss man eben auch sehen,
klar, die USA sind so ein eigenes Land und alles dieses und jenes,
aber Aber diese USA besteht eben auch zum großen Teil aus Leuten,
die starke Beziehungen nach Europa haben.
In jedes einzelne Land. Deutsche, Franzosen, Iren, Briten,
Italiener, alles nennenswerte, wichtige Bevölkerungsgruppen in den USA,
die bei aller Durchgedrehtheit nicht ein beliebiges Spiel mitmachen,
die auch selber aktiv eine Vielzahl an wirtschaftlichen Beziehungen zu der EU
haben und die alle unter irgendwelchen Zollandrohungen und sonstigen Verbotsmaßnahmen usw.
Leiden werden und das wird nicht unbedingt dazu beitragen, dass Trumps Approval
Rating weiter nach oben geht.
Da ist sicherlich auch irgendwann so ein Punkt erreicht, wo dann eben auch noch
der Kongress, also die Republikaner, über die wir schon gar nicht mehr reden
als Partei, dann doch auch nochmal eine Art Widerstand entwickeln werden.
Also ja, es wird weiter eskalieren, es wird aber nicht beliebig eskalieren können.
Irgendwo ist so ein Punkt erreicht, aber ich glaube, der ist noch lange nicht erreicht.
Ja, was ich mich auch noch gefragt hatte, war so, ob die USA jetzt eigentlich
isolationistisch oder expansionistisch wird unter Trump.
Weil irgendwie sieht es ja gerade nach beiden aus.
Auf der einen Seite sagt er, America first und die Welt muss selber sehen, wie sie klarkommt.
Auf der anderen Seite möchte er halt, wie wir schon gesagt haben,
Kanada, Grönland, Panama und den Gazastreifen gerne annektieren.
Das ist jetzt nicht gerade isolationistisch. Das heißt, vermutlich kann man,
ich meine, gut, am Ende wird es eigentlich eins von beiden sein müssen.
Im Moment scheint Trump irgendwie beides zu wollen.
Aber ja, also er passt irgendwie in kein Schema rein und es macht halt auch keinen Sinn.
So das macht halt alles vorne und hinten keinen Sinn gerade und ich meine was,
womit man rechnet die USA hatten schon immer,
isolationistische Phasen so vor und nach dem ersten Weltkrieg waren da so Phasen und dann,
ja, deswegen wird das jetzt für eher wahrscheinlich gehalten weil meisten Amerikaner
verlassen das Land auch nicht.
Das Land ist eigentlich groß genug, hat genug Rohstoffe und Natur und so und
die können, also die können sich schon,
von der Welt ein ganzes Stück weit isolieren, wenn sie wollen.
Also leichter als die meisten anderen Länder auf dieser Welt.
Aber ob es dazu kommen wird
so und gerade natürlich als Finanzstandort und es ist natürlich auch ein Riesen
für die USA als Finanzstandort ist Trump auch ein Riesenproblem er könnte sich
zu einem Riesenproblem entwickeln, weil wenn,
die Justiz nicht mehr unabhängig ist kannst du auch keinen erfolgreichen Finanzplatz
betreiben so ganz einfacher Punkt Und im Moment hat man nicht den Eindruck,
dass Trump darauf aus ist, gerade das Recht und die Justiz zu stärken in den USA.
Ja, was ja auch schon vorhin, ich meine, die Frage ist, blufft Trump?
Die stellt man sich natürlich ständig. Ist das irgendwie jetzt alles 4D-Schach,
was er macht und macht er durch seine Ansagen?
Versucht er eigentlich nur den Gegner irgendwie?
Ist das irgendwie Verhandlungsstrategie oder ein Bluff? Und was immer er tut,
zum Teil funktioniert es.
Also Europa erhöht jetzt seine Rüstungsausgaben, was ja immer aus irgendwelchen
Gründen erklärtes Ziel war.
Aber auf der anderen Seite haben wir festgestellt, dass es derzeit so aussieht,
als hätte er eher eine Amateurmannschaft ins Spiel geschickt,
die überhaupt nicht weiß,
was sie gerade tut und dass Trump selber nicht weiß. was er wirklich tut.
Und insofern würde ich sagen, ja, er blöfft, aber nicht unbedingt erfolgreich
oder nur bedingt erfolgreich.
Und insofern denke ich.
Trump ist einfach simpel, ist keine sophisticated Person und deswegen ist sein
Weltbild simpel und er kann nur simple Lösungen verstehen und fahren und das
erklärt dann auch seine Beliebtheit bei simplen Leuten.
Und wir versuchen alle viel zu viel, glaube ich, hinein zu interpretieren in,
das, was er tut und ich fürchte, so außer das, was wir beim letzten Mal auch hatten,
Transaktionalität und Narzissmus sind so seine wichtigsten Motivatoren und,
ja, Kompetenz ist da eher nicht zu vermuten.
Wie alt ist er jetzt 80, ne?
Mhm.
Mann, Mann, Mann.
Ja, aber er kommt gut zur Ruhe. Er hat jetzt im ersten Monat an zwölf Tagen
Golf gespielt, in den ersten 30 Tagen.
So, allerdings, ach ja, was wir noch nicht erwähnt hatten, was gerade durchs
Netz geht noch bei dem Macron-Besuch,
hatte er irgendwie ein größeres Hämatom, Bluterguss auf der Hand,
der nicht gut aussah und wo jetzt gerade Fotos von durchs Netz gehen und wieder
natürlich Spekulationen verursachen, wie lange Trump denn überhaupt noch mit
uns und bei uns sein wird.
Aber gut, aus einem Bluterguss aus der Hand kann man jetzt nicht relativ viel
schließen. Aber ja, das ist das Letzte, was gerade um den Block getrieben wird.
Du weißt, was das Weiße Haus gesagt hat, wo er das her hat, diesen blauen Fleck.
Nee.
Weil er den ganzen Tag so viele Hände schütteln muss.
Ah, verstehe.
Ja, also, klare Antwort. Dann wissen wir Bescheid.
Ja.
Gut ich denke wir machen
jetzt mal schluss ich denke so schlimm dass irgendwie alles ist und sinnlos
dass auch alles gerade ist es hat zumindest auch ein paar positive effekte dass europa wenig,
Wie heißt es so schön? Ein Ruck geht durch Europa mit unklarem Ausgang,
aber ich glaube Europa kann einen
Ruck gebrauchen und am Ende kann es für Europa sogar von Vorteil sein,
sich ein wenig aus dieser permanenten, selbstverordneten US-Abhängigkeit zu befreien.
Auch wenn es erstmal ein hoher Preis sein wird den man vielleicht dafür zu bezahlen
hat, weil einfach wirtschaftliche Beziehungen nicht mehr so laufen und so weiter aber.
Es wird auch mal Zeit, dass irgendwie Europa ernst genommen wird und dazu muss
man natürlich auch erstmal ernsthaft handeln und muss vor allem geschlossen
handeln und das haben wir einfach in den letzten Jahrzehnten zu wenig gehabt, viel zu viel,
Nationaldenken, viel zu viel Isolation innerhalb des Landes.
Natürlich werden wir weiterhin dieses Problem haben mit der mit den russischen
Stiefelleckern und Zuträgern in Österreich, in Ungarn in,
auch in Deutschland natürlich also eigentlich überall du hast überall so eine
ist halt einfach gerade mal so total hip so eine faschistische,
Partei zu haben, die so super rechts ist, die irgendwie so super antivog ist
und gegen irgendwie alles, was irgendwie Sinn macht,
was einzuwenden hat, weil sie einfach dafür eine Unterstützung bekommen im Wählervolk,
denen einfach alles eigentlich auch egal ist und die alles brennen sehen möchte, warum auch immer.
Aber das muss nicht das Ende vom Lied sein.
Es kann auch durchaus sein, dass es schnell wieder in so eine Gegenbewegung
führt und wir auf einmal feststellen, dass ja,
andere Kräfte wieder übernehmen. Blitzt mein Optimismus durch,
ich entschuldige mich jetzt schon dafür.
Ja, nee, man kann festhalten, noch ist nicht alles verloren.
Trotz Einbußen des großen Schadens, der bereits entstanden ist.
Und langfristig gesehen, finde ich, kann ein Ende der US-Vorherrschaft auf der
Welt auch ja, vorteilhaft sein.
So, kurzfristig nicht, aber so auf lange Sicht betrachtet.
Hat die USA nicht nur Positives gebracht, der Welt, so, und war auch in vielerlei
Hinsicht nicht immer der Gute.
So, Also im Vergleich aber natürlich mit Russland und China bisher eine ganz, ganz andere Dimension.
Aber ja, es ist nicht so, dass die USA nicht immer wieder auch sehr auf ihren
eigenen Vorteil bedacht gewesen wäre.
Und mit großem Geschick, muss man sagen,
es geschafft hat, sich auch global Vorteile zu verschaffen und auf Kosten im
Übrigen auch wahrscheinlich auf Kosten vieler Länder und auf Kosten von Ungleichheit.
Und ja und positiv könnte auch sein, dass Trump so viel Chaos verursacht,
dass Russland sich zerlegt,
wegen Trump oder durch Trump, wir werden da mal sehen, dass das einfach, ja,
für so viel Verwirrung sorgt aber ja.
Ansonsten war es das erstmal von uns würde ich sagen Das war es dann erstmal von uns und wir hoffen.
Dass wir in einem Monat oder in ein paar Wochen vielleicht mehr Positives berichten können.
Aber ja, die Welt im Moment ist wieder verrückt geworden.
Genau und wir hoffen, dass ihr nicht verrückt werdet. Lasst euch nicht von allem runterziehen.
Das geht immer auf und ab und von daher not all is lost. Das kann auch wieder besser werden.
Wir sagen Tschüss und bis bald.
Macht's gut.